RESOURCES IN WATER COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER AND A GOOD
MORNING OR AFTERNOON I SHOULD
SAY TO ALL- IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THEM THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING AN ESSENTIAL HEARING AS
MAY NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUE
TO HAVE ACCESS. TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC
AND OUR EMPLOYEES AS WE COMPLY
WITH THOSE ORDERS WERE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE CAPITAL WITH ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- I THINK SENATOR BOARD
JUST IS IN OUR- PARTICIPANT
ROOM RIGHT NOW WE SEE VIRTUALLY
THERE SIR- SO- FOR MEMBERS WHO
WILL BE ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY PLEASE MOVE MAJOR PHONES
OUR COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK AND I ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
QUESTION JUST USE THAT RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. I KNOW WE'VE BEEN OVER
THAT TEST- BUT EACH TIME YOUR
KNOWLEDGE TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING FOR
WHAT YOU LIKED ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. T. PERSONNEL PUT
PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE
DONE SO ONCE RECOGNIZE A SPEAK
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND THE
BILL NUMBER TWO WHICH YOU ARE
REFERRING. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SUCH A
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
ONE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PUT
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PROTESTS PICK TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED. ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND ALL ANNOUNCES. HERE NOW.
THE NUMBER. ONE EIGHT FOR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHT TWO SIX. THREE SEVEN
SEVEN TWO. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AN AWARD
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR. TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
NEEDED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINING
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARING IS CLOSE A MANNER AS
THE IN IN AS CLOSE THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR.
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
USE THESE NEW OR- ONLINE TOOLS
ARE TECHNOLOGY SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES SO THEY CAN
BE HEARD- WE HAVE SIX TOES ON
THE AGENDA TODAY- AND BEFORE
WE- HEAR THE PRESENTATION OF
THE BILL'S LET'S A- STEPS A
QUORUM. MEMBERS JUST MAKE SURE
YOUR MIKES ARE ON WHEN OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT CALLS THE
ROLE. SPEAK CLEARLY TO THE
MIKE. CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL. HER WILL. STERN HERE.
STERN HERE JONES- PHONES HERE
ALLEN. ALLEN HERE COME EURO
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON HERE
JACKSON HERE MORNING HERE
MONNING HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM
OKAY- WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED- I KNOW WE DID SO
BRIEFLY EARLIER BUT JUST
RECOGNIZE THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FROM-
THE DISTRICT OFFICES OPEN
PARTICIPATING COMMENTS
QUESTIONS AND DEBATE TODAY BUT
WILL BE VOTING AND THAT IS
BETTER THAN SENATOR BOARD IS
HERE TODAY SO WELCOME SIR.
LET'S START WITH OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE BILL ON A
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO OR
ONE TO GIVE MEMBERS A CHANCE AS
ANYONE TO REMOVE A MEASURE FROM
CONSENT. MOVED TO- THAT'S A
MOTION TO MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BY SENATOR JACKSON
MEMBERS JUST MAKE SURE MAKES
HER ON AGAIN AND CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
FILE ITEM TO SB NINE EIGHT
NINE. STERN HI BURN ALL RIGHT
JONES HI JONES ALL RIGHT ALLEN.
ALLEN ARE YOU CAN EURO
HERTZBERG. HUESO JACKSON HI
JACKSON ARIF MONNING AYE AYE
MONNING ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT I
WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
FOR OTHER MEMBERS. OKAY LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
WHICH I THINK IS GOING TO BE ME.
A COUPLE POINTS BEFORE I
SYMBOLICALLY PASSED THE GAVEL
HERE TO OUR VICE CHAIR. THIS
BILL IS A SPECIAL ORDER
BUSINESS. SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT MEANS WE HAVE ONE
HOUR TO COMPLETE OR DOUBLE
DELIBERATIONS ON THIS MEASURE I
HOPE IT DOESN'T OCCUPY THE FULL
HOUR BUT WE WANT TO BE
ACCOMMODATING I'M I'M REALLY
GONNA ASK WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AT TO COMPLY WITH.
OUR THREE MINUTE. OPENING LEAD
TESTIMONY AND THEN FOR THE UP
PUBLIC SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PERIOD OUT WE'RE GOING TO URGE
AND BEG YOU SAID LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE MEASURE-
I WILL LIMIT THIS ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY- TO TEN MINUTES PER
SIDE SO. WITH THAT CENTER
JONES- HERE. IN HER MIDDLE
GROUND AND- I'M GONNA JUMP.
INTO IT I'M I'LL BE PRESENTING
FROM HERE YEAH OKAY ANSWERS
TERMS AND PRESENT FROM HIS DESK
SINNERS JOURNAL BE PRESENTING
SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. YOU
GOT THE FOR CERTAIN VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND TO THOSE LISTENING IN FOR
JOINING IN THIS CONVERSATION WE
HAD A SIMILAR MEASURE A FEW
YEARS BACK WHERE WE WERE
LOOKING AT WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING
BUT SPECIFICALLY IN IN TRUCKEE
HUNTED SPECIES FROM AROUND THE
WORLD THAT- WERE IN DANGER-
THERE WAS A ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT
THE EFFICACY OF. OF THAT
STRATEGY AND REALLY TRY TO PLUG
WHAT WE SEE IS A HOLE IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH
TO- INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BUT CIRCUMSTANCES
HAVE INVOLVED- AND WE'RE NOW
SEEING NOT JUST ISSUES IN
TRAFFICKING OF. PARTS BUSTS
OTHER SORT OF QUOTE UNQUOTE
TROPHIES BUT ALSO IN
TRAFFICKING OF OTHER WILDLIFE-
SPECIES THAT FRANKLY SHOULDN'T
BE COMING INTO OUR STATE- THAT
THE DON'T POSE A SIGNIFICANT-
BENEFIT TO SOCIETY HERE AND
REALLY FRANKLY POSE ADDITIONAL
RISKS WHETHER IT'S A RISK OF.
SYNODIC INFECTION- AND WE STILL
OBVIOUSLY DO NOT HAVE THE
ORIGINAL AND PROGNOSIS FOR WHAT
CAUSED COLLUDED BUT- THERE ARE
STE THERE IS A FAIR AMOUNT OF
SPECULATION THAT. THERE WAS A
TRANSFER- FROM ANIMAL TO
PERSON- BUT MORE BROADLY. THE
TRADE IN WILDLIFE BOTH
IMPORTANT AS WELL AS A SALES
POSES REALLY A THREAT TO OUR
ECOSYSTEMS OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE BY DIVERSITY IN THIS
STATE- SO WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO STAY FOCUSED HERE IN
PROVIDING THE TOOLS NECESSARY
TO GET DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS- FROM. ANIMAL
TRAFFICKING IN SALES THAT COULD
HAVE A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON
THEIR HEALTH- THE WELFARE OF
THE STATE AND FRANKLY- THE
WELFARE OF BY DIVERSITY ACROSS
THE WORLD WE ARE IN A MASS
EXTINCTION EVENT- MAKE NO
DOUBT- IT'S HAPPENING ON OUR
SOIL HERE. WITH YOU LOOK AT-
SPECIES LIKE THE MOUNTAIN LION-
OR EVEN OUR OWN SALMON
POPULATIONS- BUT ABROAD AS
WELL. AND I CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE SIT IDLY BY AND NOT
TRY TO BRING THIS BILL BACK AND
MAKE ANOTHER PUSH- BECAUSE THE
STAKES ARE JUST TOO HIGH. HENCE
THE REASON FOR BRING IT UP THIS
SESSION IN A TIME WERE REALLY
TRYING TO LIMIT JUST OUR MOST
URGENT LEGISLATION- THE BILL%
WAS VETOED. A FEW YEARS BACK AS
IF YOU RECALL- BY GOVERNOR
BROWN. CAN IN THE IN THE
INTERIM PERIOD THE SITUATION IS
NOT GOT MUCH BETTER- WHETHER
FOR ENDANGERED AFRICAN LIONS-
OR RHINOS. LEOPARDS BUT ALSO-
SPECIES LIKE PANGOLINS- BABOONS
INFECTED HAD A SIGNIFICANT-
DOWN TICK. SO I'M OUR HOPE IS
THAT THIS WON'T BE A FEW LACK
FROM THIS LEGISLATURE SHOULD WE
PASS THIS LEGISLATION AGAIN-
AND THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOME- CAN
LEND HIS OWN UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE
ON- THIS INTERNATIONAL. ABOUT
DIVERSITY CRISIS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
NEVER GAR NICE AND I WILL GET A
FEW DETAILS IN A BIT- AND I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME LEAD
WITNESSES HERE NICHOLAS SACKETT
WITH SOCIAL PATTERSON
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS BRENDAN
COMING TO THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVALS. THANK
YOU CENTER STAND ONE OF YOUR-
WITNESSES IS HERE IN THE ROOM
FOR TWO OR THREE NICOLAS SECOND
IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT.
AND WE'RE LIMITING THE FIVE TO
THREE MINUTES BETWEEN TWO IN.
FASTER WHAT HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS A CLOSE SECOND
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION PROGRESS SPONSOR OF
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE A SINISTER
DETESTED SPECIES FOCUSED ON THE
PORTION OF THIS BILL ARE AND
INDEED IMPERILED THE CALIFORNIA
IS NOT POWERLESS TO HELP SAVE
THESE ANIMALS STATE LEGISLATION
IS AN UNDER APPRECIATED
CONSERVATION TOOL. A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE SECTION SIX FIVE
THREE- WHICH BANNED COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITY IN A NUMBER OF SPECIES
DESPITE BEING LEGAL UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AT THE TIME IN FACT
US FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE
SPECIAL AGENT STATION IN
CALIFORNIA OUTSIDE AT SIX FIVE
THREE- IS ONE OF THE MOST
USEFUL TOOL THE COMBATING
WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING CALIFORNIA
SIX IPOS BECOME THE SPEED BUMP
IN STAVING OFF EXTINCTION FOR
MANY OF THE LISTED ANIMALS AND
THIS BILL CAN CAN BE A TOOL TO
HOPEFULLY REVERSING DECLINE AND
THE DECLINE WERE SEEN AN ICONIC
AFRICAN SPECIES. A ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE ALSO. PROVISIONS
THAT WILL HELP REDUCE CHANCES
OF THE UNITED DISEASE OUTBREAK
I DON'T NEED TO RECITE THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN- BUT GLOBALLY A
QUARTER OF HUMAN DEATHS ARE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. ABOUT 60%
OF THESE DISEASES ARE
CONSIDERED CHIU NANAK MEANING
THEY JUMPED FROM OTHER ANIMALS
TO PEOPLE. AND MORE THAN 70% OF
THE NINE DISEASE'S ORIGINATE
WITH WILDLIFE. AS ONE EXAMPLE
AMONG MANY IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE THE FIRST MONKEY POX
OUTBREAK AMONG PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES WAS TRACED TO A
SINGLE SHIPMENT OF EXOTIC
RODENTS IMPORTED FROM GHANA.
FOR THE PET TRADE. THE OUTBREAK
SPREAD TO SIX DIFFERENT STATES.
BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN OTHER
DANGERS ILLNESSES LIKE SARS
MURDERS EBOLA. HIV DERIVED FROM
WILDLIFE AND SCIENTISTS BELIEVE
THE MAJORITY OF ALL FUTURE
EMERGING INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
IN HUMANS WILL CONTINUE TO
ORIGINATE FROM WILDLIFE. ONE
NINETEEN ALMOST CERTAINLY
ORIGINATED IN A BAT MADE THE
JUMP TO OTHER SPECIES LIKELY A
PANGOLIN AND FROM THERE TO
HUMANS ALL THIS OCCURRING IN A
LIVE ANIMAL MARKETS- NINETEEN
OUTBREAK HAS LED TO NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING ELEMENT. YOU WHEN AND
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
TO CALL FOR BANDS RESTRICTIONS
ON THE LIGHT ON LIVE WILDLIFE
TRADE. LAST MONTH A BIPARTISAN
GROUP OF SIXTY MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS SENT A LETTER CALLING
FOR A GLOBAL BAN ON LIVE ANIMAL
MARKETS AND TO THE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE IN LIVE
WILDLIFE. AS THE GLOBAL
POPULATION BALLOONS TO EIGHT
BILLION AND COUNTY AND WE MUST
TAKE STEPS BTH THE SAVE OUR
PLANET'S WONDERFUL ANIMALS AND
PROTECTOR ON HEALTH AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I BOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN OUR NEXT WITNESS
IS BRENDAN CUMMINGS- AND I
UNDERSTAND HE'S ON THE PHONE.
SO MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU CAN-
CALL OF BRENDAN CUMMINGS PLEASE.
MR COMING YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M BRENDAN
CUMMINS OF THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE TRADE
POSES A SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO
CALIFORNIA IN THE WORLD BY
DIVERSITY AS WELL AS OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BY EXTENSION OUR
ECONOMY. UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION LIVES WILD ANIMALS-
IMPORTED INTO THE UNITED STATES
EACH YEAR WITH MANY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF ADDITIONAL WILDLIFE
PARKS ALSO BROUGHT INTO THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND. AND STROKE
THE- MAY SPECIES SUBJECT THE
GLOBAL WILDLIFE TRADE ARE
THEMSELVES HIGHLY IMPERILED.
PANGOLINS AN AFRICAN ELEPANTS
ARE EXAMPLE. FOR OTHER SPECIES
THE TRADE REPRESENTS A THREAT
TO NATIVE WILDLIFE. SAMPLE IN
CALIFORNIA BULLFROGS WERE FIRST
IMPORTED FOR FOOD BUT IT'S
BECOME ESTABLISHED IN THE WILD
DISPLACING OUR NATIVE SPECIES
AND CARING LEASES BUT IT
DEVASTATED MADE OF THEM TO BE.
TWO MILLION OR MORE LIFE BOTH
CRYSTAL INTO CALIFORNIA EACH
YEAR EVEN THOUGH OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES HAVE BANNED
THEM AND OUR OWN FISHING IN
COMMISSION ALSO CALLED FOR THE
BAND. SIMILARLY CALIFORNIA HAS
ONLY ONE NATIVE SPECIES TURTLE
BUT HE DOESN'T SPECIES OF NON
NATIVE TURTLES ARE FOUND IN THE
WILD IN OUR STATE. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND LIVE TURTLES
ARE IMPORTED INTO CALIFORNIA
EACH YEAR INTENDED EITHER AS
PATTERNS- THAT WORLD WITH MANY
MAKING THEIR WAY INTO THE WILD
THE ACADEMICS FOR OVER THE
THREE MINUTES IF YOU CAN NOT
WRAP UP IN A COUPLE SINCE IS
PLEASE. YES WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS RELATIVELY MODEST BILL IS
A CRITICAL STEP IN REDUCING THE
SUBSTANTIAL RISKS THAT WILDLIFE
TRADE POSES TO THE PEOPLE AND
WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CUMMINGS AND- WE JUST WENT
ABOUT A MINUTE OVER ON THAT SO.
YEAH OKAY. ALRIGHT SO WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE- SUPPORTERS IN
SERVE A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE IT WILL
LOOK FIRST TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. IF THERE'S ANYONE IS
HERE DOESN'T LOOKS LIKE SO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE IS THERE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE- WE'LL TAKE THAT THOSE-
COMMENTS NOW LIMITED TO NAME.
AFFILIATION AND- WE WERE GOING
TO COMMIT TO ABOUT TEN MINUTES
ON THIS. OKAY THE FIRST LINE IS
NINE SIXTY EIGHT GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
YOU- MY NAME IS MINUTES SIMILAR
TO OFFER. EVIDENCE A CALIFORNIA
VITAMIN INTEREST MEANS HIM UP
WITH MISTER MODERATOR DEAL ONE
AND POINT IT EXCUSE ME THAT MS
MISTER MOON NOT OFFER IS A-
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL- IF WE CAN- PUT THE-
SECRETARY ON HOLD AND GO BACK
TO SUPPORTERS. OF THE BILL
PLEASE. THANK YOU. MR MARIN
WERE LOOKING FOR. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORTING THE MINORITIES IN
THIS YOUR LINE IS OPEN VICTORY
AGAINST ASHLAND A AND WE'RE AND
THE CORE OF THE BILL WHERE IN
THE BAY AREA. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
ANGELA RICHARD WITH WILD EIGHT
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER MODERATOR HOW MILLER
THE LINE HOW MANY LINES DO WE
HAVE WAITING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE- TEN
LINES THAT HAVE CUED UP ALL
RIGHT GREAT THANK YOU. TAX
PLEASE. ALL RIGHT THE NEXT LINE
COMES ON THE LINE OR NOT THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY
THIS IS JULIE WALTERS- FROM
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA AND I
REPRESENT DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE WHICH WAS MEMBERS
AROUND THE WORLD AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TOTHE
LINE OF THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATIE JONES OF THE
BERKELEY ANIMAL RIGHTS AND
ANIMAL BURKE THE NRA CENTER AND
WERE IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS DOCTOR CRYSTAL
HE OF BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I AM
WITH THAT HARMONY AND WE
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
OKAY. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE
OF LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JUDY
MAN CREW SO- SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION AND THEY'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ANNOUNCED THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO DIAL ONE YEAR
OLD IN ORDER TO GET THE
MODERATOR ON THE LINE. FOR
LISTENERS WHO DON'T KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE TO DIAL ONE RURAL AND
NO POUND SIGN TO GET MODERATOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
REMINDER. MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
EXTRA GONNA GO TO THE WIND
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARC LEISHMAN DEL WITH
CINEMA ANIMAL RIGHTS CENTER AND
I AM IN FAVOR OF THIS BE ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
RUN OUT OF THE LINE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER SEVEN
MONOMAKH LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND
CORD ABOUT THANK YOUNG. NEXT IN
LINE TO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS KATARINA ZIVKOVIC
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
FOR THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF
ANIMALS AND HE DOES MORE THAN
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION MEMBERS
WITH THE QUARTERS INCLUDING
ALMOST THREE QUARTERS OF NOT IN
CALIFORNIA YOU ARE YOU TO
SUPPORT AT ELEVEN FORTY FIVE
BECAUSE WHILE PARKING. LIKE
MARKET WHEN YOU TO PUT THE
HUMAN POPULATION **** BUT
NOTHING ANIMAL TO A TERRIFYING
PAINFUL THAT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SABRINA ACTION I'M THE
STATE DIRECTOR FOR THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR STERN FOR CARRYING THE
LEGISLATION WE HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SENATOR AFTER
FROM THE BILL THE PATH AND
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT IMPERILED
WILDLIFE ANIMALS. WE ANTICIPATE
TAKING A POSITION IN THE COURT
VERY FAN AND SUBMITTING A
LETTER THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO THE WIND SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANKS TO
THE CANADIAN TO THE SPONSOR MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA ORANGE LINE-
GENERAL COUNSEL OF ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL CALLING
FROM OUR LOS ANGELES
HEADQUARTERS AND FOR OUR
SUPPORTERS AROUND THE WORLD IN
SUPPORT. WE ALSO SUBMITTED
WRITTEN WRITTEN TESTIMONY ONCE
AGAIN IN SUPPORT FOR SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELCOME
PROPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT. NEXT IS LINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MISTAKENLY
ENTERED THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU DO WANT TO ENTER THE
QUEUE IT'S ONE ZERO IF YOU WANT
TO REMOVE YOURSELF YOU CAN USE
ONE ZERO AGAIN THAT WILL REMOVE
YOU NEXT LINE IS THIRTY SEVEN.
PLEASE HI THERE THIS IS KEITH
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ZOOS
AND AQUARIUMS AND WHY WE DON'T
YET HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION.
WE'D LIKE TO GET THERE WE HAVE
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO GET TO YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION- MOVING FORWARD
BUT WE SUPPORT YOUR- EFFORTS
AND- THE NOTIONS THAT ARE
BEHIND THIS BILL AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET TO A SUPPORT
POSITION. SO THANKS VERY MUCH.
NEXT IS LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
POSSIBLY YOU HAVE YOUR ME ABOUT
NON. MOVING ON. THE NEXT LINE
IS LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND FIFTY THREE WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. MOVING ON WE
HAVE LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONLY THEN CAN I BAY
AREA RESIDENTS IN SUPPORT OF
THE. NEXT IS LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN POSSIBLY
MUTED YOUR ONLINE. TO MOVING ON
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT IT.
IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IT
IS ONE ZERO OUR LINE IS NEXT
LINE IS LINE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
EXCUSE ME SIXTY ONE LINE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIXTY ONE WE CAN HEAR YOU.
MOVING ON. OUR NEXT LINE IS A
LINE AT FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DALE SHOWS
HIM A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND NUMBER STATEWIDE WERE
FIRMLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
AS SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALL- THE THEM BUT A BILL THE
FIRST ONE ZERO. SMARTER HOW MEN
ARE NEXT LINE IT HOW MANY MORE
LINES DO WE HAVE A- WE HAVE TWO
THAT HAVE CUED UP SO FAR OKAY
IN NEXT ONE IS- SIX EXCUSE ME
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS JERRY BROWN IN WITH
THE SENDING OF COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION- WORRY- ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. AS FAR AS I CAN
YOU KNOW FOR LIKE IN JUMP IN
REAL QUICK FOR THOSE THAT ARE
LISTENING ON THE LINE WE ARE
YET WE'RE LOOKING FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE- BY SENATOR STERN
IF YOU'RE WATCHING THE
COMMITTEE ON ON YOUR ONLINE
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT DELAY
BETWEEN WHAT'S HAPPENING LIVE
HERE AND YOUR- DISPLAY SO
PLEASE PAY ATTENTION TO THE
TELEPHONE LINE. WHEN YOU'RE
CALLED BY THE MODERATOR NOT THE
COMPUTER BECAUSE YET YOU'LL
MISS YOUR TURN IF YOU'RE
LISTENING FOR YOUR TURN TO COME
UP ON THE COMPUTER SO PLEASE
LISTEN ON THE TELEPHONE LINE.
FOR YOUR LINE OPEN UP MODERATE
WILL TAKE. AT THREE MORE LINES
IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IT'S ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR LET'S TRY ONE MORE
TIME- AS A FINAL CALL FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE PLEASE DIAL ONE ZERO NOW
SO THE MODERATOR MAY
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU. MODERATOR. ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE THAT'S
CUED UP HERE CAN'T WILL TAKE
THIS IS THE LAST ONE. THEY JUST
DISCONNECTED HERE WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE ELSE CUED UP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATE SHOWING THAT THAT-
CONCLUDES WITNESSES IN BOTH
ROOMS AND ON THE TELEVISION ARE
ON THE TELEPHONE WILL MOVE TO
THE TWO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL IN
SEVENTY FIVE BY INNER STERN WE
HAVE TO IN THIS IS ON THE PHONE
MR MUNOZ MOON NO THE WHAT FIVE.
THE PERMANENT SECRETARY OF THE
MINISTRY OF ENVIRONMENT CLIMATE
TOURISM AND HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WITH THE REPUBLIC OF
ZIMBABWE. AND CATHERINE SPENCER
FROM THE ENVIRONMENT RESEARCH
CENTER. MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN CALL IT MISTER MOON NO DO
OFFER A FIRST PLEASE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
MELISSA NOT OFFER IMMINENT
VICTORY FOR ENVIRONMENT AND
TOURISM IN ZIMBABWE ZIMBABWE'S
NOT SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL FOR
THE FOLLOWINGREASONS ONE ALL
THE ICONIC SPECIES MENTIONED IN
THE IN THE DOCUMENT. IN YOU
KNOW A CASE THE NUMBER OF-
STABLE AND- INCREASING SOME OF
THEM I IN FACT CLASSIFIED IS
PASSED BECAUSE OF ABUNDANCE
SECONDLY WE HAVE THE COMMUNAL
AREAS MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR
INDIGENOUS RESOURCES MANAGEMENT
IN ZIMBABWE BENEFITING EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS IN
BIKE POPULATION FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE. IN DR REVOLVES AROUND
HANDING SAID BILLY THE- WITHIN
PUBLIC HAS PUT ASIDE IN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION. ACTIVE
OF LAND. OUTSIDE FINISH PARKS
SO THAT IT CAN BEEN. HUNTING
AND THEREFORE IF WITH MOVE THIS
IF THE BILL PASSES. I MEAN THIS
LAND BASED NO INCENTIVE FOR YOU
TO REMAIN ON THE WILDLIFE. I
ALSO WANT TO GET THAT THE APPLE
SO WE SET OUR CORTES WILL
HUNTING BASED ON FINE IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT TIME SAKE. AND WE
FOLLOW FIGHT IS PROTOCOLS IN
TERMS OF MANAGEMENT OFF THE
SPECIES. I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT TO WIDE WE HAVE BOTH
PHOTOGRAPHIC AND SOMEBODY
HUNTING WE WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS UP THE CAMINO AREAS
WHAT MAY NEED TAKES PLACE DAY.
THE BENEFIT THEY GET IS FROM
HUNTING THEY GET ABOUT 55% OF
THE PROCEEDS. IF THE COMMUNAL
AREAS IN THIS A LOT IF THE THAT
AREA OF THE WAY PEOPLE ARE VERY
POOR IN THE OF NO ON THE SOCIAL
FLIGHT. AND WOULD DEFINITELY
BEEN NEGATIVELY AFFECTED I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT DAY THEY
ARE. LITTLE THE IN THE NATION
THE- READY THE WAY THE U. S. IF
FOR ANY. TO WHAT THESE BILLS
SEEK TO DO YOU. CAN DECIDE TO
PROTOCOL OFF WHICH BOB WE AND
YOU A- OR ANY PARTIES. SO I
GAVE WE'VE BEEN THAT BECAUSE
THAT REASON YOU MAY WISH TO
RESPECTIVELY CONCEDE THAT THE
POINT AND WE WANT ALSO TO POINT
OUT THAT IS MENTIONED IN THE-
THEY USE NOR DEREK LINK THAT IS
BEING ESTABLISHED BETWEEN THE-
ANIMALS. AND THE DISEASES THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SO YES
COMMITTEES A VERY BIG PROBLEM
WHICH WE HAVE TO DO WITH. BUT
WE CAN'T DESTROY ALL THE
DEFAULT ON CONDITION THAT WE
HAVE PUT BECAUSE WE THINK. AND
WE ARE NOT DEFINITE. IN THIS
AREA WE NEED TO MAKE SIGNS
BEST. DECISION WE BELIEVE
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS- IN
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE AT THAT
INSTITUTION NOT JUST IN THE
PUBLIC BUT THE WHOLE OF SUBJECT
WE HAVE THESE ANIMALS. WE USE
IMPROPER HOLD BY THE WEIGHT THE
SECOND LARGEST ELEPHANT
POPULATION IN THE WILD IT THANK
YOU FOR THAT. IN IN FEDERAL IN
CAPACITY. FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
ELLICOTT. ALL THE NUMBERS WE
OKAY. WE HAVE TO GROUP. EFFORTS
CONSERVATION MIND COME FROM
BEHIND. SO WE BEHIND THE HIGH.
IT'S SIMPLY MEANS THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO COME OF BILLS I MEAN.
AND IN FACT WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN USED TO ALL PROCEEDS WHAT
WE INTEND TO DO THROUGH. PROOF
PROOF PROOF THIS BILL SO
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS
CHAIRMAN WE STRONGLY OFF. IT
DID THE PROPOSED THE ENACTMENT
AND IN FACT WILL HAVE MEDIA
FULL VERSION OF THE DOCUMENT
WHICH WE CAN PUT ON LINE AS
SOON AS WE GET YOUR INDICATION
TO DO THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER BERNARD
WOEFULLY INCOMPLETE. WE
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US
ANYTHING IT'S ABOUT MIDNIGHT
WHERE HE IS RIGHT NOW- SO WE
WILL OF IT OVER ON THE WITH%
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL GO
GIVE A MINUTE OR SO TO MS-
SENSOR FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESEARCH CENTER. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN. HELLO
CATHERINE SENSOR PLEASE. GO
AHEAD LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
KATHERINE SENSOR AND I AM A
RESEARCH FELLOW WITH THE
PROPERTY AN ENVIRONMENT
RESEARCH CENTER AS WELL AS THE
AFRICAN WILDLIFE ECONOMY
INSTITUTE. IN AFRICA THE
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES IN REVENUE
PROVIDED BY HUNTING HAVE A
CLEAR TRACK RECORD OF
CONSERVING THE HABITAT
NECESSARY ICONIC WILDLIFE
SPECIES TO TRY. AGAIN AFRICA
CONSERVE THE AREA OF HABITAT
MORE THAN SIX TIMES THE SIZE OF
THE U. S. NATIONAL PARK SYSTEM
SHOULD HELP KEEP REMOTE AREAS
REMOTE SOMETHING RECOGNIZED AS
CRITICAL TO PREVENTING VIRAL
SPILLOVER SHRIMP AND ON THE
DISEASE HUNTING ARGUES ALSO
ENABLE RURAL COMMUNITIES TO
DEVELOP THE INFRASTRUCTURE ON
WHICH PUBLIC HEALTH DEPENDS
SUCH AS ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
NECESSARY TO WASH ONE CAN. THE
COMMITTEE RECOGNIZED THE
TRUSTEES OF THE GAME SPECIES
DEFIED THE LEGISLATION ARE NOT
GOING TO PREVENT. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE IMPORTATION OF
THE SPECIES. ARE ALREADY
SUBJECT TO INSPECTION AND
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS BY THE
US. PREVENTING THE NEXT
PANDEMIC REQUIRES YOU TAKE A
THOUGHTFUL AND TARGETED
APPROACH TO WILDLY TRAIT. AS
WRITTEN LEGISLATION DOES NOT DO
THAT AND RESPOND REMINDING
CONSERVATION AS WELL AS A
MECHANISM FOR PROVIDING THE
MEANS AND INFRASTRUCTURE IS
JUST A CARD PUBLIC HEALTH IN
AFRICA AND AROUND THE WORLD. TO
ACHIEVE ITS CONSERVATION PUBLIC
HEALTH GOAL I THINK IF THE
COMMITTEE ABANDON THE BAN ON
HOW MUCH OF THE IMPORT JANICE
CHEN AND PURSUE A MORE TAILORED
IN. SPACE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MRS IN SERVICE MISS SIMMS
APPRECIATE THAT- WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARK SMITH
THAT WAS ASKED TO PRESENT
OPPOSITION FOR A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES OF THE PHONE SO I'LL
LIST THEM NOW- THOSE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL INCLUDE THE ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION. CAL
YOUR ASSOCIATION. THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE WILD
SHEEP FOUNDATION. CALIFORNIA
HOUNDS MEN FOR CONSERVATION.
THE CAL OR WETLANDS AND
WATERFOWL COUNCIL. THE TULARE
BASIN WETLANDS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA BOWMAN HUNTERS STATE
ARCHERY ASSOCIATION. THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA CHAPTER OF
SAFARI CLUB INTERNATIONAL. THE
BLACK WORKING GROUP. THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION- JUROR
NO VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SMITH
OTHER WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE. HI YES CHAIR MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE WE
BELIEVE THAT. CAME ANIMALS NEED
TO BE MANAGED BY SCIENCE AND
POPULATION NEEDS NOT A MOTION
THANK YOU THIS IS THE SAME
WATER PHELPS'S DISASSOCIATION
THAT TESTIFIED. ON THE PHONE.
RIGHT OKAY GREAT THANK YOU- AND
OF THE WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE WITNESSES IN TWENTY
FORTY. MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN QUEUE UP WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE FOR SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IT'S ONE
ZERO. FIRST LINE IS A LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GERMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROY GROUP OF SPEAKING
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THIS BILL
WE WOULD LIKE TO CALIFORNIA
GAME WARDENS SPEND THEIR
PRECIOUS TIME PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA GAME WARDENS ARE.
PREDICTING CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE AND OUR WATER NOT.
EXOTIC SPECIES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. MISTER MODERATOR HOW
MANY WITNESSES DO WE HAVE
LINING UP. WE HAVE SEVENTEEN SO
FAR LET'S GET THROUGH ONE BY
ONE. OKAY NEXT IS LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PUBLISHERS CAN MAKE MAN
CHAIRPERSON OF SOUTH
SACRAMENTO'SCHAPTER IN ALREADY
MEMBER STRONG OPPOSITION. OKAY
NEXT. NEXT IN LINE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CATHY ONCE REPRESENTING OUR
CLUB INTERNATIONAL THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OUTDOORS
WORKING COALITION CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA SPORTSMAN BLOBBY
ALL IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAM CREDITS
REPRESENTING DONALD IS
CALIFORNIA IN THE EXTREMELY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
THIRTY TWO IF YOU HAVE YOUR ME
BUT NONE. YES MY NAME IS
KENNETH BUT CHARITY I LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO I'M A BOARD
MEMBER TO SACRAMENTO SAFARI
CLUB A CHAPTER OF. SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE NINETY TWO POSSIBLY
YOU MUTED YOURSELF. MOVING ON
NEXT IN LINE IS SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY FIVE. HELLO.
MOVING ON OUR NEXT LINE IS A
LINE AND NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND I
HAVE. DID YOU ARE YOU GONG ROLE.
MISS MERRY LET ME LET ME JUMP
IN REAL QUICK FOR THOSE AGAIN
AS A REMINDER THOSE WATCHING
THE COMMITTEE ON TELEVISION OR
ONLINE THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
DELAY FROM WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE BE LISTENING
TO YOUR PHONE- AND THE
MODERATOR FOR YOUR- TURN TO
SPEAK NOT THE NOT THE SCREEN.
PLAY AGAIN PLEASE LISTEN TO
YOUR PHONE NOT THE SCREEN- SO
YOU CAN BE TOLD WHEN YOU'RE IN
Q. THIS MY RARE. IN NYC OKAY
NEXT WILL GO TO THE LINE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO OUT. ONE SHOT MANY
SACRAMENTO SAFARI CLUB STRONGLY
OPPOSED. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
MILLION ON THE NEXT LINE IS
LINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE THIS IS ALEX. FEEL
CALIFORNIA. TIME IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HAS.
BEEN IN AFRICA MANY TIMES AND
LIVED THERE FOR FIVE YEARS-
THIS BILL WILL BE DETRIMENTAL
TO THE SURVIVAL OF WILDLIFE
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON LINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MINE
ONE HUNDRED. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE ONE NO ONE IS YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT MY. LINE
ONE ALL ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE NEXT WILL GO TO
THE LINE ONE ZERO TWO ONE TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
MY NAME'S JOHN MEANT TO COME
CALLING YOU FROM WILLOWS
CALIFORNIA. BASED ON HUNTING
FISHING AND PHOTO SAFARI TRAVEL
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY AND FOR
SOUTHERN AFRICA COUNTRIES
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANKS. NEXT. NEXT IN LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ON NEXT WILL GO TO
THE LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS OUT OF ENTERTAINMENT
AND I'M DEEPLY OPPOSED TO THIS
AND I AGREE WITH- WHAT THE MAN
FROM ZIMBABWE SAID. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO THE WIND SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
A MILLION I'LL BE TWO LOGICAL.
OF AMERICA IN OPPOSITION WE DO
HAVE TO BECAUSE MY MATERNAL
WITHIN WORK WITH THE CENTERS OF
THE SMOKE THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO THE LINE ONE ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY LINE WENT UP FOR YOU
ARE I'M SORRY THIS IS ROBERT
DATES FROM PLACERVILLE
CALIFORNIA- I HAVE MY USE SIDE
BY CERTAIN SCOUTMASTER I'VE
BEEN IS IN BAB WAY FOUR TIMES-
STRONG OPPOSITION TO ALL I CAN
VALIDATE THE STATEMENT BY THE
MINISTER- FROM ZIMBABWE SOMEONE
IS ACTUALLY BEEN THERE. THANK
YOU NEXT. ON THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE UNDER
POSSIBLY OF YOUR MUTE BUTTON ON.
AND IT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PEOPLE QUEUED UP IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY MISTER MAHER
IS GIVE A COUPLE MORE SECONDS
MISTER SMITH WE DID HAVE A
QUITE A FEW KEY AMERICA OUR
NOTES ON THE FOLLOW LET'S GO TO
THE LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY AND I L<c.cyan>G TWENTY</c>
YOU ARE LINE TWENTY. GREAT JUST
ONE THING TO THE MODERATOR ON
NO ONE IS GETTING ON AND
TELLING US WHAT OUR NUMBERS ARE
SO WHEN YOU'RE CALLING FOLKS NO
ONE KNOWS THAT THAT THAT
THEY'RE CUTE AND THEN TURN OFF
THEIR MUTE BUTTON SHE SAID THAT
MANY- MY NAME IS MICHAEL I MEAN
WITH THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION AND WE ARE
DEEPLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
NEXT NEXT WE'RE GOING TO THE
WINDS OF SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. EUROPEN GO AHEAD
HEARING WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO LEAD.
SPEAKER SAID NO ONE IS COMING
AND GIVING US OUR LINE NUMBERS
AS DAN READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA WEREN'T STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MODERATE HAVING MORE
LINES WE HAVE. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE TWELVE THAT ARE CUED UP
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE TWO
MARKERS WERE PASSED THE TEN
MINUTES- SO TO MORE PLEASE. IT
WAS BACK ALL I KNOW I. COURTESY
TO MORE LIVE ONES. NEXT PLEASE.
YEP WELL OVER THE LINE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT IS. LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND. HI MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA CUT OFF
THE PHONE LINES AT THIS POINT
TIME MISTER SMITH DID YOU WANT
TO COME UP AND JUST SAY
SOMETHING REAL QUICK ON AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU WERE TRACK IN
THE PHONE LINES OR SOMETHING SO
MARK SMITH AGAIN- ON BEHALF OF
SOMEBODY WHO CAN CALL IN THE
CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMAN'S
FOUNDATION WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITE TO THE
MEASURE THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS THAT YOU'RE ARE THAT YOU
COULDN'T GET IN THAT. NOT AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I
AM AN- ENGINE THAT MOST OF THE
FOLKS THAT ARE. TAKING
OPPOSITION HAVE REGISTERED
THEIR OPPOSITION VIA EMAIL OR
LETTER. I WOULD- ASKED FOR
THOSE THAT ARE ON THE LINE THAT
HAVE I'M ON BOTH SIDES OF
SUPPORT AND- OPPOSITION IF YOU
ARE ABLE TO GET ON THE LINE
TODAY I THINK THE GENERAL. WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IS ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO EMAIL THAT IN AND- WE
WELCOME THOSE. COMMENTS THIS IS
JUST THE FIRST COMMITTEE FOR
THIS BILL IT'S GOT SOME
COMMITTEES TO GO AND GET IN
ADDITION TO THE FLOOR. AND SO
THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME TO
REGISTER BALL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- SEEN IT THERE'S NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE WILL
BRING THE DISCUSSION UP TO THE
DíAS MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION ON
ALL OF. SEVENTY FIVE BY.
SENATOR STERN BEFORE WE START
THAT CENTERS I. BEEN OFFERED
ARE YOU EXPECTING IN RENTS ARE
TODAY YES HI. THANK YOU. ANY
ANY DISCUSSION FROM THE DíAS.
CENTER CABALLERO AND I CAN'T
SEE BORDERS IF HE'S TRYING TO
CHIME IN OKAY YOU GUYS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A SENATOR
COVER COME THERE AND THEN
CENTER BOARD JUST WHO'S ONLINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR- AND LET ME JUST START
OFF BY SAYING THAT I YOU
SUPPORTED YOUR OTHER BEARD
BILL. THAT HAD TO DO WITH THE
AFRICAN. I HAVE ICON SPECIES
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A FULL
WORD THERE THAT I'M MISSING-
AND I. BUT THIS BILL IS
DIFFERENT. AND IT'S DIFFERENT
BASED ON MAY AMENDMENTS LATE
MA'AM MA'AM AND MEN MINTS AND
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT- I
HAVE A REALLY UNUSUAL SITUATION
IN MY DISTRICT THAT- IS CAN
CONTINUALLY. AT RISK- I HAVE A-
A GENTLEMAN WHO HAS A SMALL
BUSINESS A NON PROFIT RESCUE-
AND IT'S I THINK THE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN DEALT WITH IN THIS IS
THAT IT'S A LOGICAL ASSOCIATION
LETTER SO I WON'T GO. WITH THEM
AND IN DETAIL- IT SOUNDS LIKE-
THEIR POSSIBILITY OF HAVING A
CONVERSATION AND WORKING IT
OUT. AND YOU KNOW IF THAT
HAPPENS THAT'S GREAT BUT RIGHT
NOW THIS WOULD KILL KILL HIS
OPERATION AND- FOR THAT REASON
I'M GONNA BE I'M GONNA BE
LAYING OFF. SO I URGE YOU TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION VERY
REASONABLE PEOPLE- AND I. WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO COME AND
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS. AT HIS SO
IT THERE IT'S REAL. AWESOME
WITH THAT I'LL I'LL JUST IT.
THANK YOU SO CARILLO BOARD.
IT'S DIFFERENT EVERY TIME HE
TRIES. IT LOOKS GOOD GOVERNMENT
IN IRAQ OFF COURT. TRY ONCE
MORE YOU HAD IT THE FIRST TIME.
YEAH YOU'RE GOOD THANK YOU I
DON'T KNOW FOLKS KNOW THIS ONE
OF THE BOTTLES KEEP ON COMING
UP ON THE SCREEN BATTERY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT I'VE BEEN
TOLD ON HOW TO CONDUCT THE
MEETING BUT I ALWAYS I I'D LIKE
TO ONE. I THANK THE CHAIR OF
DEVICE YOU'RE IN THIS SITUATION
ALONG ME TO COMMENT- PERHAPS I
CAN DIRECT MY QUESTIONS. REALLY
IT'S I THINK IT'S JUST ONE. AND
IT HAS TO DO WITH- SEVERAL
PREEMPTION. YEAH I WAS LOOKING
AT THIS AND THIS REALLY IS A
COMPOSITE BILL OF. TWO POSSIBLY
THREE THAT. MIGHT BE HELPFUL IF
THEY WERE IF THEY WERE DRAFTED
SEPARATELY BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT- IN ORDER FOR US TO GET
CERTAIN THINGS THEY END UP WITH
THAT WITH THE CALL THE
PRIORITIES THAT WAS DONE THIS
WAY NINE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT IF I CAN POSE A QUESTION
THROUGH THE SHARE HER. TO THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. IS THE
ISSUE OF FEDERAL PREEMPTION
AND- I'M GONNA READ. A SECTION
HERE THAT. CAPTURES MY
ATTENTION. THAT SAYS ANY STATE
LAW. FOR REGULATION WHICH
APPLIES. TO THE IMPORTATION OR
EXPORTATION ARE OF ENDANGERED
SPECIES ARE THREATENED SPECIES
IS A BOARD. TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT PROHIBITS WHAT IS AUTHORIZED
PURSUANT TO AN EXEMPTION OR
PERMIT PROVIDED I IN THIS
CHAPTER SO MY QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR OF THIS IS. I IMAGINE
THIS FEDERAL PREEMPTION ISSUE
EXISTED WHEN THIS WAS DEALT
WITH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. BUT
HOW DO WE NOT JUST A GREAT THAT.
THERE IS FEDERAL PREEMPTION BY
THE CLEAR LANGUAGE OF THE
STATUTE POSSIBLY YOU CAN FEEL
PREEMPTION- ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO
DO MORE RESEARCH ON THAT BUT
MAYBE IF I COULD JUST POSE THAT
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR HOW DO
YOU ANTICIPATE OVERCOMING. WHAT
HERE'S TO BE CALM. DID THE LAW.
THROUGH THE CHAIR THE ABSOLUTE-
THANK YOU SENATOR. WE WRESTLED
WITH THIS ISSUE SQUARELY-
FRANKLY WE WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAD
A WE THOUGHT A WORKABLE
FRAMEWORK BUT WHEN POWER
CHANGED HANDS. AND THE AND THE
IMPORTATION LAWS WERE AMENDED-
AND CERTAIN COUNTRIES WERE SORT
OF GIVEN BLANKET EXEMPTIONS FOR
IMPORTATION WE FELT THE NEED TO
STEP IN- WE ADDED AMENDMENTS.
SINCE THE LAST TIME WE BROUGHT
THIS BILL FORD THAT WE THINK
ADDRESS THAT FEDERAL PREEMPTION
ISSUE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE- THE
BILL IS MORE FOCUSED- LESS
FOCUSED ON SORT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL PRACTICES AND MY
CAN APPRECIATE WHAT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION IS SAID ABOUT. THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT BANNING- THIS
HUNTING- IN AFRICA- AS WELL AS
THE IMPORTATION OF WHATEVER
THEY CONSIDER A TROPHY INTO THE
UNITED STATES- ARE BILLS REALLY
FOCUSED HERE ON- WHAT HAPPENS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE THINK
THAT- WELL THE BILL ACTUALLY
DOESN'T- DOESN'T ACTUALLY DâN
THE HUNTING ITSELF- THE
IMPORTATION IN POSSESSION OF
THOSE TROPHIES WE FEEL LIKE THE
STATE IS ON PRETTY SOLID LEGAL
GROUND THERE- TO BE TO BE
ADDRESSING THAT WITHIN OUR OWN
BORDERS THAT WE DON'T INTRUDE
BOTH ON SITE EASE. AS WELL AS
FEDERAL LAW I WE RECOGNIZE THAT
MAY BE AN ONGOING DEBATE GOING
FORWARD- BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR-
THIS BILL IS ROUGHLY ABOUT.
THAT PORTION THE BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT THE TROPHY AND NOT THE
HUNT ITSELF REGARDLESS OF HOW
FEEL. I'M PERSONALLY. INCOME
WITH THE NOTION OF. SHOOTING AT
M. OR TAKE THE ANIMAL ANY
ANIMALS LIFE FOR PURPOSE OTHER
THAN FOOD IT SEEMS STRANGE TO
ME TO GO- SHOOT A BUNCH OF
AFRICAN LIONS ELEPHANTS- UNDER
THE AEGIS OF CONSERVING THEM-
BUT I THINK WE'LL HAVE TO SET
THE EFFICACY OF THAT PRACTICES
SIDE HERE AND REALLY JUST FOCUS
ON. THE TROPHY ITSELF- AND
POSITION AND SALES WITH IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S OUR THAT'S
OUR ARGUMENT. MISTER CHAIR
RIGHT DO A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
FOR. WELL MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT NEW JERSEY FELT THE SAME
WAY THAT THEY TOO WANTED TO
FIND WAYS AROUND THE FEDERAL
PREEMPTION ISSUES AND
ULTIMATELY LOST SO. I GUESS MY
FINAL QUESTION WOULD BE SHOULD
WE AS A COMMITTEE. RACKLEY
AUDIE ANTICIPATE THAT THIS WILL
FIND ITS WAY INTO THE COURTS IN
BASED ON THE PRESIDENT THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN JERSEY. OUR
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS PROVISION
WILL BE KICKED OUT IN THE
COURTS. A LOT SOONER STERN
EITHER ANSWER THAT ORG OR KICK
IT TOO IS GAS AND I AND I CAN
ADDRESS BRIEFLY MY CLOTHES BUT
I THINK I AND NUMBER SACKETS
HERE JUST TO DIG INTO JUST A
LITTLE MORE LEGAL NITTY GRITTY
FOR PURPOSES OF THE PUBLIC
RECORD AND LET HISTORY HERE SO.
SURE SO NEW JERSEY HAD TO DO
WITH SALES AND- THE STATE
DECIDED NOT TO DEFEND THE
LAWSUIT ACTUALLY WAS NOT
ADJUDICATED AND ALSO I JUST
WANNA GIVE ONE EXAMPLE. OF WHY
WE BELIEVE THIS WON'T BE
PREEMPTED- YOU NEED TO GET-
FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE
PERMITS FOR LIVE ANIMALS- TO
pBUT- LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN
SAY HEY. EVEN THOUGH THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE SERVICE GAVE YOU A
PERMIT TO BRING THIS TIGER AND-
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE A
LIVE TIGER IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THIS IS THE SAME PREMISE
IS. THE FEDS CAN GIVE YOU
PERMIT TO BRING INTO THE
COUNTRY BUT WE'RE SAYING YOU
CAN'T POSSESS IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. SO IT'S
MORE OF A STATES RIGHTS
ADVOCACY POSITION GOT ITS ACT
YEAH YOU GOT IT SO. I'M FOR
SMALL LOCAL OUR STATE BASED
GOVERNMENT. CAREFUL CAREFUL NO
I KNOW I I'M I'M I'M GONNA GET
YOUR VOTE ALL OF A SUDDEN-
THANK YOU FOR RAISING THE ISSUE
THE SENATE. CENTER BARGES
ANYTHING ELSE. MISTER MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE THE WITNESSES ON THE
LINE STILL- MISTER MOON NEED TO
OFFER OR MS SENSOR. GO AHEAD
YOUR LINES ARE OPEN. I JUST
WANT ASSN US IS A CENTER JONES
I JUST WANT TO ASK- PERMANENT
SECRETARY MOON TO OFFER IF HE
COULD- JUST ADDRESS MAYBE A
COUPLE OF SPECIES THAT AS
ZIMBABWE'S BEEN TRYING TO.
MANAGE THROUGH THIS PROCESS IN
A THE LIONS OR THE ELEPHANTS
POPULATIONS ABOUT IN ZIMBABWE
CAN YOU- KIND OF EXPLAIN HOW
THIS BILL WOULD. PENDER OR
HELP- THOSE POPULATIONS. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
REGARDS TO THE ELEPHANTS EXACT
CD IF WE ARE GOING TO. GET THE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS IF IT'S COLD
CAMPFIRE IS COMMUNITY BASED SO
IF THE COMMUNITY IS THAT GET
THE- THAT REVISION YOU'LL FROM
HYUNDAI NOW IF THE BILL EFFECT
OFF THE BILL IS SUCH THAT IT
CRIMINALIZES HAVING TROPHIES IN
CALIFORNIA. EFFECTIVELY IT ALSO
MEANS THAT PEOPLE WILL NOT HUNT
WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT. COM YOU
THAT'D BE GET THE OUT. FROM
HUNTING WILL NOT HAVE THAT
LATELY QUOTE. THE CURRENT STATE
OF OUR ECONOMY IS SUCH THAT WE
FIND CONSERVATION SOLD THE
CONSERVATION FUND ARE COMING
FROM HANDING WHICH I'VE FEET
BEHIND BEST WHICH I'VE WHICH I
NEED ALSO TO HIGHLIGHT THAT FOR
VIOLENCE. YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
DO HIGH AND I OWNED IT THE EDGE
OF YEARS. AND YOU CAN ONLY HI
THEY MAY. THAT ABOUT SIX OLD
NOTE IF. NOT TOLD THE AGE OF.
THIS STRUCTURE ALSO OR TO AND
IF I. H. RESTRICT BUT ALSO WE
STICK TO MAY. DATA ABOUT WE SIT
IN TRADE SHOW IN TEN OF A- YOU
KNOW WORDS YOU'RE NOT IN THE-
WITH DEADLY BACK. OFF THIS. YES
SIMPLY MANAGING OUR DOOR THAT.
OLD ENOUGH OR TECHNOLOGY. WITH
THAT. SO CAN YOU THE. I THINK
THAT THAT'S CREATURE HELP THAT
TO NEED TO BRING OUT IN THIS
DAY. WE THINK AND IN THIS THAT
SORRY YES YES YOU MAY GO AHEAD
OKAY THEY THINK YOU'RE THE THAT
KIND I WANT TO GIVE A MISTER
SERVICE OPPORTUNITY TO AND HI
OF THE THAT SHE UP IN A TEST
READ. THE SCIENCE PA PLATFORM
ON BIODIVERSITY AND ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES REPORT WHICH WARNED
THAT A MILLION SPECIES ARE AT
RISK OFEXTINCTION DOES THAT
REPORT IDENTIFIED LEGAL
REGULATED HUNTING AS A CAUSE OF
THOSE EXTINCTIONS. IT DOES NOT
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU- I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT'S THE LIMIT OF MY
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS I WANT TO
GIVE OUR WITNESSES ESPECIALLY
MISTER MOON TO OFFICE SINCE HE
IS CALLING ALL THE WAY IN FROM
ZIMBABWE AND I THINK IT'S- YOU
NO LATER THAN MIDNIGHT THERE-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. YOU
KNOW I'LL SAY. AND ONE OF THE
WITNESSES I'M NOT A MEMBER OF
SAFARI CLUB INTERNATIONAL- I'M
NOT ON THE BOARD. I'VE YOU KNOW
I'VE- I'M NOT THAT STRONGLY
AFFILIATED WITH THEM BUT I HAVE
BEEN TO A COUPLE OF THEIR-
ANNUAL BANQUETS IN SAN DIEGO
AND I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A BIG
ONE AND- I THINK RENO NEVADA.
AND I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE ON THE
DíAS IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO
ONE OF SAFARI CLUB OR
NATIONALS- ANNUAL BANQUETS TO
ATTEND ONE. AND IF YOU'VE NOT
EVER BEEN INVITED TO ONE I CAN
HELP MAKE THAT HAPPEN I THINK.
BUT YOU'LL REALLY SEE THE ACT
I'LL TO WHAT WAS WHAT WAS. I
WAS TAKEN WITH IS THE CARE AND
CONCERN. THAT PEOPLE TO SUPPORT
THIS ORGANIZATION HAVE. FOR
ANIMALS NOT JUST HEARING IN
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT AROUND THE
GLOBE PARTICULARLY THE
CONSERVATION EFFORTS THAT THEY-
USE. IN AFRICA AND OTHER
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES THE AMOUNT
OF AMERICAN DOLLARS. THAT GOES
TO SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD. THOSE
CONSERVATION EFFORTS WOULDN'T
HAPPEN ES VIBRANTLY IS A DO IF
IT WASN'T FOR AMERICAN DOLLARS
NOW COURSE THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT SUPPORT
THOSE THOSE THOSE EFFORTS AS
WELL. BUT THE PROFESSIONALISM
THE CARE THE CONCERNED THAT
THESE FOLKS EXHIBIT TOWARDS
MAKING SURE THAT THESE ANIMALS
ARE CONCERNED THAT THESE
HUNTING LANDS ARE CONSERVED SO
THAT THESE ANIMALS CAN SURVIVE
AND CONTINUE AND NOT GO
EXTINCT. IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE
AND I THINK THAT THE STORIES
THAT WE GET SENSATIONALIZED
HERE IN UNITED STATES ABOUT
HUNTING IN THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES A LOT OF TIMES WERE
NOT GIVEN THE COMPLETE STORY
THAT IT'S POACHERS. THERE ARE-
TRESPASSING ON TO THESE
RESERVES AND PRESERVE. IT'S YOU
KNOW PEOPLE THAT AREN'T
FOLLOWING THE LAWS AS THESE
COUNTRIES HAVE THEM SET UP TO
PROTECT THESE ANIMALS AND I
THINK FOR THE MOST PART WHEN
CALIFORNIANS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THIS ACTIVITY THERE DOING IT
LEGALLY THEY'RE DOING IT
MORALLY THEY'RE DOING IT-
HONORABLE IN WITH THE MINDSET
OF. THEY WANT TO PERPETUATE THE
SPECIES. ARE CONTINUALLY SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'LL SAY AND
I SEE THAT I- EXCITED SOME
EXCITED IS SOME. COMMENTS FROM
CENTER ALANSON AROUND WELL I
JUST I GUESS I AM I AM I WAS
LOSING YOUR COMMENTS SENATOR
AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT THE
COMMENTS WERE MADE BY THE
AUTHOR I MEAN I KNOW IT DOES
SEEM COUNTERINTUITIVE. TO YOU
KNOW TO EQUATE HUNTING WITH
PRESERVATION AND- SERVE IN SOME
RESPECTS LIKE I HEAR YOU I ALSO
KNOW THE SAME TIME. SOMETIMES
THE GREATEST CHAMPIONS FOR- YOU
KNOW FOR WHAT FOR OUTDOOR SPACE
AND IN FACT. YOU THAT FOUND THE
FATHER OF THE- OF THE MODERN
NATIONAL PARK THE ROOSEVELT
LARGELY WAS. MIA MADE HIM HIS
PASSION FOR THE NATIONAL PARKS
AND PRESERVATION OVER SPACE WAS
WAS DONE BECAUSE OF HIS LOVE
FOR HUNTING. YOU KNOW I THINK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF MY OWN
TRAVELS IN AFRICA I WELL I'VE I
WENT TO A RWANDA AND HAVE THE
CHANCE TO GO AND- SEE THE
GUERRILLAS THERE IN THE IN THE
JUNGLE AND I AM CERTAINLY
SENSITIVE TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP BY THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE MINISTRY.
ABOUT HIM. ABOUT THE MONEY THAT
THE- TERRORISTS BRING INTO
BECAUSE I WASN'T HUNTING WE'RE
JUST LITERALLY GOING TO SEE
THESE. THESE BEAUTIFUL ANIMALS-
IN. INDIA BUT BUT THE MONEY
THAT IS BROUGHT IN FROM
TERRORISM IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
IN HELPING TO FIND. THE EFFORTS
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT AND
ULTIMATELY IT'S THE LUNAR THE
LOCAL VILLAGES IN HAND TO STAND
UP AGAINST THE POACHERS BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT THEY- ARE
GETTING MONEY FROM. THE
GOVERNMENT. THAT IS LARGELY
FUNDED BY THE TERRACE TO COME
IN AND SEE THAT THE GUERRILLAS.
WHERE WHICH TURNS ASSOCIATED
WITH CLIENTS A DOZEN OF HUNTING
IN PEOPLE CONSERVE IN HIM SEE
THE ADAM WITHOUT KILLING SO
ANYWAY I JUST I WANT TO I'M AYE
AYE GODS WE SHARE YOUR PASSION
FOR- PROTECTING INTERNATIONAL
BIODIVERSITY AND I. YOU KNOW
I'VE NEVER SEEN THE- THE
ATTRACTION TO. SEE A BEAUTIFUL
HOME IN THE IN THE WILD AND
WANTED TO. SHOOT IT DOWN. YEAH
SO I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS HERE CENTER BUT I DO I
DO WANT TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS
ON. THIS DIFFICULT BALANCE-
THAT EXISTS EVEN THOUGH YOU AND
I MAY NOT SHARE THIS EAT US-
INVOLVING- HUNTING ANIMAL TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
SOMETIMES OVER POPULATION I
KNOW WE HAD ALL DEBATE OVER
KANGAROOS IN AFRICA THEY-
CERTAIN AFRICAN AUSTRALIA.
TOWARD YOU KNOW- THEY SEE IT AS
A YOU KNOW THE PAST- OR THE
GOOD LOOKS OVER POPULATED. AND
THERE IS A WAY TO GET ANYA IN
THIS THIS VERY COMMITTEE WELL
SOMETIMES IT WE APPROVE BILLS-
TO ALLOW FOR INCREASED TAKE. OF
CERTAIN ANIMALS- WE DO ALLOW
FOR HUNTING OF ANIMALS- IN OUR
OWN STATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
LONG AS IT'S DONE IN A WAY
THAT. YOU KNOW PROPERLY
PRESERVES AND PROTECTS- THE
ADEQUATE NUMBERS- FOR ABOUT
ADVERSITY SO I LOVE I YOU KNOW
I GUESS MY QUESTION VIEWS DO
YOU HAVE SORT OF AN ABSOLUTE
OPPOSITION. TO ANY HUNTING. OF
THESE ANIMALS IN AFRICA- DO YOU
SEE HOW DO WE HOW DO YOU
RESPOND TO THE KINDS OF
ARGUMENTS ADMIT BASIN AND- I.
DO YOU HOW DO YOU SEE. YOURSELF
MOVING THE DAY. WITH THESE
KINDS OF IN MIND. IT WAS ISLAND
ME RE THE COMMITTEE THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT FIVE MINUTES LEFT.
ONE HOUR TIME LIMIT NOT
RECOGNIZE ROLE DINNERS WITH
CHOOSE TO GO THERE ARE. IF WE-
I THINK AT TWO TWO BUT I DO A
TO RE. THIS WERE OR ABOUT FOR
TIM UP AGAIN THE ONE HOUR MARK.
I'LL BE THERE VERY BRIEF IN
MADE ELABORATE FURTHER IN MY
CLOSING ELSE DID HONEST RESPOND
CENTER COPYRIGHT. I CLOSE TO
APPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK THERE.
ON SAY VERY BRIEFLY- REGARDLESS
OF MY FEELINGS ABOUT HUNTING.
TIGHTENING DANGER SPECIES. BUT
THIS BILL DOESN'T STAND HUNTING
OF THOSE SPECIES. AND THE
EFFORTS THAT YOU KNOW WITH THE
FACT THAT. THEY'RE PAYING ME
YEAH FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR- HUNTING FEE FOR AN
AFRICAN ELEPHANT OR THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM MALE
AFRICAN LINE AND- IF WE DO IN
FACT TRUST THOSE GOVERNMENTS TO
GET THAT MONEY BACK TO THE
PEOPLE OF WHICH- THERE'S BEEN A
MIXED RECORD. FRANKLY IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY GETTING THAT TO
COMMUNITY BENEFIT BUT- SETTING
SETTING THAT ASIDE- THIS WOULD
DO. NOTHING TO ACTUALLY
INTERVENE AND WHATEVER THAT
KIND OF. ALLEGE CONSERVATION
COMMERCE IS- THIS HAS TO DO
WITH THE TROPHY AND BRINGING IT
BACK TO CALIFORNIA- IF THE
HUNTERS. RIDGE CARE ACT HEY. I
WANT TO TAKE THEM AT THEIR WORD
THAT THEY DO HAVE. MORAL AND
SHIN DENNIS SORT OF. EITHER
THEN IN IN THAT HUNTING ACTIVE.
TAKE A PICTURE AND COME HOME.
WHAT WHY DO YOU NEED A TROPHY
TO COME BACK TO CALIFORNIA WITH
TO SHOW WHAT YOU'VE DONE- IF IT
REALLY IS ABOUT. THE SORT OF
PROUD WAS THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH WHATEVER THAT QUOTE
UNQUOTE TROPHY IS- TAKE A
PICTURE AND PUT IT ON YOUR
INSTAGRAM. IF THAT IF THAT YOU
THINK WILL EARN YOU THE STRIPES
BUT- I DON'T THINK THAT
COMMERCE. AND FRANKLY A BLACK
MARKET THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT KIND OF COMMERCE AS ANY
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
BEYOND OUR JURISDICTION TO
REALLY REACH INTO HOW THE
GOVERNMENT OF ZIMBABWE CONDUCTS
ITS AFFAIRS AND SO. THE BILL
DOESN'T ENDEAVOR TO INTERVENE
IN THAT REGARD IT'S REALLY WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER THE FACT. THE
SENSOR ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE DíAS. CENTER JACKSON YEAH
VERY BRIEFLY- I HAVE HUNTERS IN
MY FAMILY THEY HAVE A RULE THAT
THEY ONLY. YOUR WITH THEIR
GOING TO EAT. SO THEY HAVE
TRIED TO SET SOME PARAMETERS
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. I DON'T
PARTICULARLY LIKE THE TASTE OF
MILK BUT- ARE HAD IT AND THE
COOKED RIGHT. THAT COULD BE BUT
DON'T TELL MY SON IN LAW THAT
VIDEOS AND COOKED IT RIGHT ALL
CARE DOCTOR I TAKE THAT BACK SO
BUT MY POINT IS THAT I THINK
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO DO
THIS- I THINK THERE ARE WAY TOO
MANY ABUSES. AND YOU KNOW WE
GIVE OUT HUNTING LICENCES FOR
DEER IN THE FALL BECAUSE THE
GOAL IS TO THIN OUT THE HEARD
BEFORE WINTER SET AND WHERE
THEY MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE
SURVIVE EITHER SO. I DON'T SEE
THIS IS TAKING AWAY WHAT I
WOULD CONSTRUED HUMANITARIAN
REASONS FOR HUNTING BUT- THE
NOTION THAT. A PASSING THIS
BILL WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE SURVIVAL OF WIDE LIFE I
THINK IS JUST A TERRIBLE OVER
REACH IT REMINDS ME OF A- AN
OLD QUOTE WE USED TO HAVE BACK
IN THE DAY WHEN WE HAD A WAR
GOING ON VIETNAM WAR. KILLING
FOR PIECES LIKE. **** FOR
CHASTITY- AYE CHESTER- I JUST
DON'T THINK AND THAT'S A QUOTE
THAT QUOTE I'M- FOR THE A
BUMPER STICKER. THEY ACTUALLY I
THINK THEY DID I THINK THEY DID
BACK IN THOSE DAYS BUT THE BUT
THE POINT IS THAT. AT THAT THIS
IS THE- THIS IS NOT GOING TO
END THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO-
TO HUNT GAME TO DO THINGS THAT
ARE. ECOLOGICALLY APPROPRIATE
AND I KNOW MANY OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD TODAY ARE VERY STRONG
CONSERVATIONISTS. THEY ARE
BECAUSE THIS IS THEIR
PLAYGROUND THIS IS THE PLACE
WHERE THEY GO OUT AND COMMUNE
WITH NATURE AND- AND- IN ENJOY
ITS BENEFITS AND ALSO AND ALSO
HUNT- BUT I THINK THE TO. THE
THIS CALLING THIS BILL
SOMETHING IT'S KNOCKING OVER
DRAMATIZING ITS IMPACT I THINK.
MOVES US AWAY FROM THE ACTUAL-
ESSENCE OF THE BILL AND SO I
WOULD LIKE TO. TO MOVE THE BILL
AND THEN ASK THE AUTHOR TO- YOU
KNOW TO KEEP THE DISCUSSIONS
GOING- BUT I DO THINK THAT ITS
ESSENCE IS A GOOD ONE AND SO I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE. I THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THOSE THAT
ARE WATCHING THE COMMITTEE- AND
OR LISTENING TO IT THAT WE DO
THE- THE COMMERCE COMPANY DID
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAD SOME
CHALLENGES ON ON THEIR LINE.
RECOGNIZING THE NUMBERS THERE
WAS ALSO- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND IN OPPOSITION. SO IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET ON THE
LINE TO RECORD TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT AND OUR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE SEND THOSE. IN WRITING.
AND IF YOU NEED THE CONTACT
INFORMATION IT'S ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AS SOON WE
CAN JUST GOOGLE CALIFORNIA
SENATE. AMID ON NATURAL
RESOURCES IN THAT WILL COME UP.
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO RECEIVE
YOUR COMMENTS WITH THAT WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY STERN. WILL ALLOW THE
AUTHOR TO CLOSE AND THEN WE
WILL TAKE A VOTE. VERY GOOD AT
TAKING HIS CHAIR- JUST WANTED A
KNOWLEDGE CENTER CUBBY HEROES
CONCERNS AND COMMIT TO LOOKING
INTO THE ISSUE AND FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOUR LOCAL. AS WELL AS-
MISTER DUNNE'S FOLKS IN IN
LOOKING AT- WHAT SORT OF
CHANGED SINCE THE LAST VERSION
INTO NOW AND- WHAT KIND OF
NEGATIVE REPERCUSSIONS THAT
COULD HAVE- SO THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THAT. OKAY I'LL I'VE
EVER PEATED BUT AT. WE ARE ON
THE BRINK OF A MASS EXTINCTION
EVENT GLOBALLY WE ARE FENDING
NATURE DEEPLY TERMS OF HOW WE
MOVE ANIMALS ALIVE OR DEAD
AROUND THE WORLD IN TERMS OF
HOW WE EAT ANIMALS IN TERMS OF
HOW WE CONSUME THEM AND TREAT
THEM AS COMMERCE- AND THEREFORE
NOT HUMBLED IN THIS MOMENT BY
THAT OFFENSE- MINUTES GRAVE
CONSEQUENCES THAN I THINK- IT.
THE WORST IS YET TO COME- SO I
HOPE THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY PUT
SOME KIND OF CLARITY AROUND-
WHERE CALIFORNIA STANDS IN
TERMS OF CONSERVATION AND HOW
THAT CONSERVATION MISSION
REALLY ALIGNS WITH OUR OWN BIO
DIVERSITY GOALS AND OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS- WE ARE GOING TO
BE A HEALTHIER MORE SUSTAINABLE
AND MORE PROSPEROUS CALIFORNIA-
WITHOUT- THIS TROPHY HUNTING
IMPORTATION PROCESS INTO THE
STATE AS WELL AS- OTHER SPECIES
THAT MAY POSE A RISK TO OUR
HEALTH OR- BY DIVERSITY THE
STATE WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION FROM CENTER JACKSON TO
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ON SB ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE STERN. BY TURN I
JONES JONES KNOLL ALLEN. ALLEN
HI CABALLERO. HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON HI JACKSON ALL RIGHT
MONNING HI MONNING HI. FOR ONE.
THAT IS FOUR TO ONE WE'LL PUT
IT ON CALL IN THESE ONE MORE
VOTERS THAT RIGHT. RIGHT OKAY.
STERN THE SHOW IS YOURS NOW
OKAY. THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE. THEY MAKE IT
BACK TO OUR NEXT SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO. BEGIN BILL IS A
REGULAR HEARING FORM AND STE
AND TAKE AUTHORS IN FILE ORDER-
SO I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE. I
THINK THE NEXT STEP WOULD BE
SENATOR BASIS SB TEN NINETY I
BELIEVE SHE HAS BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY IN OUR PARTICIPANT
ROOM TO PRESENT AND I WOULD
JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET I CAN
RESPOND AFTER HER OPENING-
PRESENTATION BUT THIS THIS BILL
WILL BE PRESENTED. A REMOTELY
BUT JUST WANT TO GET
CLARIFICATION THAT HOW THIS CAN
BE BILL PRESENTATION BUT NOT A
VOTE TODAY THERE'S GOING TO BE
BRIEF PRESENTATION FROM THE
AUTHOR- LEAD SUPPORT. LEAD
OPPOSITION- AND WE'LL TALK
THROUGH SOME OF THE PASSWORD
AFTER THAT- SO SENATOR BATES IF
YOU WANT TO OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YUP MINE HERE ON MY
DISTRICT OFFICE JIVING WITH
YOU. BOB ON THIS SLIDE BEAL I
WANT TO FIRST THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND CERTAINLY YOUR STAFF
ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS. FOR
THE TIME AND CONSIDERATION
BEING GIVEN OUT THE BILL AS YOU
MENTIONED ALL PRESENT THE BILL
BUT I'M NOT ASKING FOR A LITTLE
TOO DAY. FOR OUR DISCUSSION
REGARDING OUT YET SERVING OUT
SOME SORT OF STRUCTURE FOR
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD. IT
IS KERN FORM SB NINETY REQUIRES
LOCAL SO COMMISSION TO FOLLOW
THE COASTAL ACT. AND GROUND HER
MEDS TO CITIES COUNTIES OF
STATE AGENCIES AND PROPERTY
OWNERS FOR THE INSTALLATION OF
COASTAL MITIGATION PROJECTS. AS
SET FORTH IN PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE THREE OH TWO THREE FIVE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ANY
CONSTRUCTION THAT WALTERS THE
SHORELINE MUST BE PERMITTED BY
THE COASTAL COMMISSION OR
PRESIDING LOCAL GOVERNMENT. TO
THAT END SB ESTABLISHES A TIME
LINE FOR THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE COASTAL COMMISSION TO
APPROVE OR DENY AN APPLICATION.
FOR A COASTAL MITIGATION
PROJECT WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
IT SUBMISSION AND WE HAVE
DISCUSSED ABOUT. DISCUSS THAT
TIME LINE AND MAYBE A LITTLE
TOO TIGHT. BUT CERTAINLY- WE
HAVE TO GET SOMETHING THAT'S
MORE CERTAIN BECAUSE CURRENTLY
THE RESPONSE TIMES FOR PERMIT
APPLICATIONS OFTEN TAKE MONTHS.
AND IN SOME CASES YEARS THERE
IS ONE IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT'S
GONE ON FOR A COUPLE YEARS. TO
APPROVE OR DISAPPROVE OF
PROPOSAL A PROJECT PROPOSAL
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE AS THE
DELAY IN THEIR RESPONSE TIMES
AND LEFT ON COASTAL BLUFFS.
VIRTUALLY UNCHECKED WE NEED
BEACH GOERS PROPERTY OWNERS
VULNERABLE TO THE DANGERS OF
COASTAL EROSION. WHICH IS WHAT
HAPPENED- IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AT GRANDVIEW BEACH IN
ENCINITAS CALIFORNIA. WHEN A
OCEAN FRONT BLUFF SUDDENLY
COLLAPSING KILLED THREE MEMBERS
OF DR PAT DAVIS IS FAMILY. WHO
HAD GATHERED THERE TO CELEBRATE
A VICTORY OVER BREAST CANCER OF
HIS SISTER IN LAW- ELIZABETH
**** HOWEVER AS YOU KNOW THAT
WASN'T THE FIRST TIME NOW THAT
IT'S HAPPENED IN OUR DISTRICT.
THE SAN DIEGO AREA TRAGEDY
FOLLOWED SIMILAR PREVENTABLE
WERE BLUFF COLLAPSES. AND THE
WILL TO CHARITIES IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE. TWO THOUSAND JEEP
TO. IN A OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHT
OKAY. BEACH NEAR THE BAY OF
STROLL BEACH IN ORANGE.
SOUTHERN REGION ORANGE COURT A
RESULT EVOLUTION DRIVEN A ROW.
YOU KNOW THE TWO NINTH AND MAY
BLOW WHERE IN THE ON MAR. PUT
THEM HIGHER. RAIL IN JEOPARDY
IN ONE BECAUSE AROUND ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
FULLY REPAIR. OF THAT. LAUGHS
THESE ARE BANDS CAN. DOWN IN
DANGER MORE LAW IF WE DO NOT
ACT. YEAH TEN NOW MAKES IT
CLEAR ABOUT THE NEED TO SECURE
BLOCKS AND SAME LIVES THEN WE
NEED TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS.
AND TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF OUR MY KEY
WITNESSES- CHARLES MAKE YOUR
IMAGE. AND DOCTOR PATRICK GAVE
US BOTH CONSTITUENTS HANDING
OUT THE NEED. SO I ASK OUR THAT
YOU TURN THE PHONE OVER I THINK
ITS TELEPHONE CONFERENCE TO
BAN. IN AT ALL SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS IN CONCLUSION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES AND AT
OUTSET I'LL JUST SAY- BEFORE-
DOCTOR DAVIS TO MAKE MR MAKE.
TERM IT'S TESTIMONY THAT- I
APPRECIATE THE SINCERITY AN
URGENCY WITH WHICH YOU APPROACH
THIS LEGISLATION SENATOR AND- I
SHOULD ALSO. THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AS WELL
AS CONGRESSMAN LEVIN FOR
REALLY- BRINGING DOCTOR DAVIS
IS TRAGEDY BEFORE US- AS HARD
AS IT MAY BE TO WRESTLE WITH
AND I WON A NOTE THAT DESPITE-
SOME OF THE OBJECTIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PARTICULAR
FRAMEWORK- PUT FORWARD HERE
TODAY- THERE ARE. SOME
REDEEMING CONCEPTS WE THINK
HERE AS- IT FOR NEAR TERM
ACTION- OPPORTUNITIES LIKE SAFE
PASSAGES THAT- WE KNOW DOCTOR
DAVIS IS BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
LOCALLY- SOME MORE HOMEWORK TO
DO ON BEACH NOURISHMENT
MITIGATION CONCEPTS. AS WELL AS
NOTCH INFILL AND- SOME OTHER
ITEMS THAT FRANKLY JUST REQUIRE
MORE DILIGENCE AND MORE TIME-
SO I'M COMMITTED TO MOVING THAT
DISCUSSION FOR WORD WITH SOME
URGENCY THIS YEAR WE ALSO KNOW
THE PRO TENNIS- WEIGHED IN ON
THIS ISSUE S IT AND WE ALSO
HAVE A- CRIME RESILIENCY BOND
THAT TOUCHES ON THE SEA LEVEL
RISE ISSUE. I DON'T THINK WE
CAN AFFORD TO WAIT ON THIS THE
TRAGEDIES ARE MOUNTING AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU SENATOR BATES- AS WELL AS-
YOUR LOCAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH COGNITION
ELEVEN IS WHAT SECRETARY
CROWFOOT AND- OF THE TIRE
ADMINISTRATION IS REALLY TRY TO
PUT OUT A FIRST DRAFT VERSION
OF. SEA LEVEL WE CAN START TO
DEAL WITH SOME NEAR TERM.
REALLY BUT ALSO DEVELOPED A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK
ARE GOING FORWARD THAT WE CAN
ALL RELY ON- AND WITH THAT-
MODERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINE TO OUR LEAD WITNESSES-
FIRST IT VARIOUS- FIRST A WE
COULD START WITH DOCTOR PATRICK
DAVIS. YOUR LINE IS OPEN DR.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON CALIFORNIA
SENATORS MY NAME IS DOCTOR PAT
DAVIS AND I'M TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF- SB TEN NINETY I'VE
BEEN A RESIDENT OF ENCINITAS
FOR FORTY YEARS. HI I APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY NOT BECAUSE I
WANT TO. BELIEVE ME IT WOULD BE
MUCH EASIER FOR ME TO GO
OUTSIDE AND GROUND IN MY
SORROWS. BUT BECAUSE I FEEL IT
IS MY RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
FAMILIES OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ESPECIALLY ANTHONY
THIS TO FIGHT FOR SAFETY ON OUR
BEACHES. THERE HAVE BEEN NO
CHANGES ON THE BEACH ON
SEPTEMBER SECOND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I LOST MY WIFE JULIE
MY YOUNGEST DAUGHTER ANY ANY.
AND MY SISTER IN LAW ELIZABETH.
THE SIMPLEST COLLAPSE. IF WE
WERE TO RATE THE DANGERS OF THE
BLOCKS IN OUR AREA ON A ONE TO
TEN SCALE WE ARE GETTING VERY
CLOSE TO PASS. WHERE THE CITY
OR STATE. THEIR CASES WHERE
THEY PLACE LIFE GUARD TOWERS I
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO FEEL SAFE WHEN THEY'RE
CLOSE TO THESE THINGS. I NEVER
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE NECESSARY
TO PICK UP MY PUBLIC OFFICIALS
TO HELP ME SAVE LIVES. THERE IS
NO PLAN FOR ST REPLENISHMENT OR
ANY OTHER BLUFF CHANGES TO
INCREASE SAFETY ON THE VERY
POPULAR STRETCH OF BEACH
BETWEEN BEACONS AND GRAND VIEW
WHERE MY ACCIDENT OCCURRED. I
WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO COME DOWN
HERE TO WALK THE BEACH WITH ME
AND SEE FIRSTHAND OUT DANGEROUS
THESE BLOCKS ARE. SEE THAT
THERE ARE SIMPLE CHANGES THAT
CAN BE DONE WHICH WOULD GREATLY
INCREASE SPEECH SPEECH SAFETY.
IT IS NOT A QUESTION OF IF.
TRAGIC BLUFF COLLAPSE I'M LIKE
THE ONE THATKILLED MY FAMILY
COULD OCCUR AGAIN. IT IS ONLY
ONE IT WILL HAPPEN AGAIN. I CAN
NOT LIVE WITH MYSELF. IF I
DON'T WORK WITH YOU TO GET
THINGS CHANGED. NO OTHER FAMILY
SHOULD FEEL THE PAIN THAT MINE
HAS. I STRONGLY BELIEVE ALONG
WITH CHARLIE WHO YOU'RE GONNA
SOON HERE PROBLEM. SB TEN
NINETY OFFERS. VERY MUCH THANK
YOU DON DAVIS FOR COURAGEOUS
TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT. OUR NEXT MODERATOR
I THINK WE'RE GONNA GO TO
CHARLIE MCDERMOTT IN MISTER
MCDERMOTT IF YOU DON'T MIND-
WE'VE ALREADY HIT- JUST ABOUT
OUR THREE MINUTE MARK SO AS
BRIEF AS YOU CAN BE. I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- I MEAN IT IS RIGHT AND
HIS FAMILY SIX ALL SERVER
GRANDVIEW BEACH- SANDFORD
BEACHES COMES A RIVERS AND
FLOWS NORTH TO SOUTH AND IT'S
BEEN BLOCKED BY THE JEDI AND
DEVELOPMENT REQUIRES MASSIVE
DREDGING WE'RE RUNNING OUT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF CUBIC
YARD DEFICIT. TO THE BEACH
DOESN'T HAVE SAN AND WORDS
FLOATED FROM THE ARMY PROJECT
ACTUALLY PUT SAND ON THE BEACH.
WITH HAPPENING IS THE PUBLIC
GETS CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THE
EDGE OF THE BLUFFS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO BEACH LET. ME KNOW
IF YOU FROM HOMEOWNER I
RECENTLY MOVED HERE AND- FROM
IN LAND AND COMMITTED TO
PUTTING SAND ON THE BEACH AS
OUR EVERYBODY HERE I'M ALSO
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO FIND.
COMMON GROUND AS SIMPLE FIXES.
THAT STAND OUT TO BE WILL PUT A
FOOTBALL FIELD THE SAND ON THE
BEACH OR A HUNDRED YEARS OF
OFFSET PROJECT FOR A FIFTY FOOT
WIDE WHAT. IS THE SIGNIFICANCE
AND TAX WE WANT TO DO MORE WHO
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU WE WANT
TO PUT- GEOLOGIC HAZARDS BASED
BUSINESS OR TOGETHER WHICH
ALLOWS US TO HAVE PROPERTY
TAXES THE BOND. FUNDS. AND
FIFTEEN. THAT SHE'D BE.
TROUBLING THIS BILL SEE WHY
STILL TO STRIKE THAT THE BILL.
BUT WE NEED A STREAM PROCESS TO
DO. CREAM REMOVAL. THREE AGE
NOT TO. LIKE THE ONE THAT THE
DAY FAMILY. ALL THESE MASSES
WILL SAY LIVES. HE'S STILL OUT
FOR SOME ROAD IN THE NOT
NOTICEABLE THE PUBLIC THE BEEN
DEPLOYED IN STATE EXTENSIVELY
IN THE AREA THE CALL SELECT
COMPLIANT THE DO NO HARM
WILDLIFE. PLEASE WORK WITH US
TO FIND A WAY. THESE
IMPROVEMENTS THROUGH THE
HOMEOWNERS ARE DESPERATE TO GO
AND FIX THE PROBLEMS ARE THE
FINER THINGS SOME OF WHICH ARE
SIMPLE COUPLE THOUSAND DOLLAR
PROJECT TO PHYLLIS CKD KITS
PLAN THAT CLAMP SHUT AND DROP A
BUNCH OF DINNER ON THE BEACH
THE SITUATION RIGHT NOW ALONG
CERTAIN SECTIONS SPEECH OR AS
DANGEROUS AS A LOADED HANDGUN
AND A PLAYGROUND. IN NINETEEN
WILL ATTACK AND- WHILE
PROVIDING A MAJOR PUBLIC
BENEFIT. I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU CAN CARRY THIS FAR AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU SIR- NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE OVER TO OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION- WILL GIVE YOU EQUAL
TIME HERE I THINK IT'S ABOUT
FOUR AND A HALF MINUTES- SO YOU
ALL CAN DIVVY. THAT FOUR AND A
HALF HOWEVER YOU SEEK BELIEVE
JENNIFER SAVAGE WITH SURFRIDER
AS WELL AS HEAR CHRISTY WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE DOING FULL
PUBLIC SUPPORT OR OP HERE IT'S
JUST GONNA BE LEAD WITNESS
TESTIMONY MEMBERS JUST TO
CLARIFY SO WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA GO OVER TO LEAD
OPPOSITION AND THEN. WE'LL
WE'LL MOVE FOR. SO MODERATE IF
YOU WOULDN'T MIND THE LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN. HI THANK YOU
THIS IS JENNIFER SAVAGE FROM
THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION THANK
YOU CHARACTER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THAT THEY NOTING
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCACY
INVESTED ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDE
BY NATURE OF PROFOUND FOCUSED
ON PUBLIC SAFETY WERE OFTEN
INSPIRED INTO EXISTENCE BECAUSE
SOMETHING OF HARMING OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE UNDERSTAND THE
DESIRE TO PROTECT PEOPLE BY
FIXING PROBLEMS AND OUR HEARTS
OUT THE FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY THIS TRAGEDY I
IMAGINE EVERYONE LISTENING CAN
RELATE TO THE SHOCK INCREASE
LEAKING LOCAL AND AN ACCIDENT
AND WE ABSOLUTELY MUST DO OUR
BEST. TO PREVENT FUTURE
TRAGEDIES THAT CALIFORNIA. WE
LOVE THE BEACHES. I'M FORTY
THERE BILL WE DO NOTHING TO
PROVIDE. GOING EXPERIENCE THE
PUBLIC UNLESS YOU CONSIDER
LIMóN THE COULD EIGHTY NINE.
BECAUSE THAT WHAT HE DO DESTROY
THE BEAT A MEETING AT THE RED.
COASTAL ENGINEER HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THE KIND OF HARD
ARMORING AND YOU CAN NINETY
ADVOCATE FOR DOES NOT MAKE
BEACH IS SAFER AND IN FACT WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE THE MORE
DANGEROUS EACH STATE IS REDUCED
OR ELIMINATED AT HIGH TIDE AND.
WITH WRITING HE- THERE WHAT
START OUT OF. TREATMENT
CRISTINA DIEGO AND COUNTY WILL
BECOME. OTHER COSTA PROPERTY
OWNERS CAN. LEADING TO THE LOSS
THE PUBLIC BEACHES ALL ALONG
CALIFORNIA. ALL OF THE IS WHY
YOU'RE CAN HAS THE AN ACT OF
ELEVEN HUNDRED EMAIL OPPOSING
THE BILL. TELL ME BETTER OPTION
EXIST ONE THAT BALANCE IT
PUBLIC SAFETY. WITH THE RIGHT
ACCESS THE BEACH WITH
PROTECTING PRIVATE INTEREST AND
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD
THE STILL AND TO HOLD ON TO
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE AS A LEADER
AND PROTECTING IT. COVERAGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
SAVAGE EARNED NEXT WE HAVE A
SIR CRISTINA BELIEVE WITH THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. IN THIS BE
THE FINAL PIECE AFTERNOON SHARE
STERN AND MEMBERS I'M SURE
CHRISTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION THE STATE
AGENCY THAT PROTECTS OUR COAST
FOR CURRENT FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THE COMMISSION HAS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. BUT WITHOUT QUESTION
EVERYONE FEEL DEEP SYMPATHY FOR
THE FILM FAMILIES WHO SUFFERED
THIS TERRIBLE LOSS IT'S A
HEARTBREAKING TRAGEDY AND IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THEY WANT TO
CHANNEL THEIR GRIEF IN THIS WAY.
MEMBERS WE MUSTN'T CONFLATE
TRAGEDY WITH THE BILL BEFORE
YOU. WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATE STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITY OVER SHORELINE
ARMORING. IT'S NOT NECESSARY IT
WON'T PREVENT A SIMILAR EVENT.
AND IT WILL HAVE A DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON PUBLIC BEACHES
COASTAL ACCESS AND CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL ECONOMY. TO BE CLEAR
THE ENGINEERS BLUFF DIDN'T GIVE
WAY BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
DENIED A RETAINING WALL TO
PROTECT PUBLIC AFETY THERE.
THE COMMISSION HAS NEVER
RECEIVED SUCH A REQUEST. NOR
HAS THE COMMISSION EVER DENIED
A PRIVACY WALL IN THIS
LOCATION. IN FACT THE ENGINEERS
ARE READY TO BE ARMORED.
TERRIBLE ACCIDENT WAS JUST THAT
AN ACCIDENT NOT THE RESULT OF
ANY ACTION BY THE COMMISSION OR
LACK THERE OF. WEAKENING THE
COASTAL ACT WON'T REMEDY THAT.
BEAR IN MIND THAT 32% OF SAN
DIEGO'S COAST IS ALREADY
ARMORED AND 27% OF ORANGE
COUNTY SO IT'S NOT AS IF THE
COMMISSION DOESN'T EVER
APPROVED SEA WALLS. WE DO ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS WITH
EXTENSIVE SCIENTIFIC SURVEYS
AND FULL MITIGATION TO MAKE
THEM CONSISTENT WITH THE
COASTAL ACT. SB TEN NINETY
PROVIDE THE COAST ELECT CAR
ABOUT FOR ALL TYPES OF
SHORELINE ARMORY THE COMMISSION
WOULD HAVE TO APPROVE SEE WALLS
BY RIGHT AND WOULD LOSE
IMPORTANT AUTHORITY OVER LOCAL
APPEALS. WOULD SET A CAP ON
SANTA MEDICATION A WHAT. WOULD
AMOUNT IN. TIES MITIGATION TO
REAL ESTATE VALUES INSTEAD OF
ACTUAL IMPACT. AND IT WOULD
EXEMPT THE WALLS CLOSE PAULA.
IN THOSE TO ACCESS. RECREATION
HABITAT PROTECTION. THE BILL IS
DESIGNED TO MAKE IT FASTER
EASIER AND CHEAPER TO BUILD THE
WALLS PRIMARILY TO PROTECT
PRIVATE RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS. AND FOR EVERY SHE
WILL THAT IS BUILT THE PUBLIC
LOSES THE BEACH. THERE ARE
BETTER OPTIONS THE COMMISSION
IS ONE OF SEVERAL AGENCIES
CURRENTLY WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
FIND SPACE PRINCIPLES TO
ADAPTED SEALABLE RIGHT
STATEWIDE. THE COMMISSION IS
ALSO WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STUFF BAKER LC PIECE.
SEVERAL BOMB BILLS INCLUDING A
REGIONAL RESILIENCY BILL BY THE
PRO TEM. AND IN ONE THAT
PROVIDED FUNDING TRIP RESEARCH
EARLY WARNING SYSTEMS TO
PREDICT WHAT WHAT'S COLLAPSE
HAVE RECENTLY BEEN HOLD THE
RECALL THAT NINETEEN. WE HOPE
THESE PROMISING BILLS ARE
INTRODUCED NEXT SESSION BUT IN
THE MEANTIME TEN NINETY SHOULD
NOT BE THE ONLY MEASURE THAT
MOVES FORWARD THIS YEAR PLEASE
HOLD THIS BILL TODAY SO WE CAN
WORK ON MORE EQUITABLE SOLUTION
NEXT SESSION. THANK YOU MY
MOTHER A LITTLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
ACTUALLY WE'RE NOT TO EIGHT
SINCE OUR OTHER TESTIMONY THE
AGREEMENT WITH THE AUTHOR WAS
THAT- WE HAVE JUST LEAD
TESTIMONY AND THEN SHE WOULD
CLOSE SO AT THIS JUNCTURE-
CENTER BATES WE WILL ALLOW YOU
TO. TO WRAP UP HERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND I THINK
WHAT'S GREAT TODAY THAT THE
DISCUSSION HAS STARTED AND OF
COURSE BOB. I THINK WE COULD
DEBATE ALL AFTERNOON OF WHETHER
OR NOT THE BILL ACTUALLY
PROMOTE SEA WALLS ACTUALLY. THE
MITIGATION MEASURES THAT ARE
MENTIONED IN THE BILL ARE TAKEN
DIRECTLY FROM. PROBABLY
RESOURCE. COLD THAT EXISTS
TODAY AND SEA WALLS ARE IN
THERE. I THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE
AGREE AND SCIENCE AGREES THAT
THAT'S THE LEAST DESIRABLE
OPTION AND CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF. IF
THIS BILL OR SOMETHING LIKE IT
BECOMES SO THE INSTRUMENT. THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING AMENDED OUT
OF THAT ALSO AS I MENTIONED THE
TIMELINE PUTTING. MORE PRESSURE
ON THE COASTAL COMMISSION THEIR
THEIR WORK PRODUCTS ON MANY
OTHER PROJECTS CAN CERTAINLY BE
ADDRESSED. SO I THINK WE HAVE A
GREAT START I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT. YOU
PROVIDED TO US SENATOR STERN
FOR DISCUSSIONS ON PREVIOUSLY
AND TODAY- MY GOAL IS CLEARLY
TO ENSURE THAT OUR INCREDIBLE
COSTA RESOURCE. ARE YOU HERE
FOR ALL TO ENJOY PROTECTING-
SURFRIDER SEND THEIR- DESTINY
INTERESTS PROTECTING OUR
PROPERTY OWNERS- THEIR VESTED
INTEREST OUR BEACH GOERS THE
SAFETY. OF FOR ALL OF US ARE.
WITHOUT A COAST. GUARD BEACH IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S KIND OF NOT
CALIFORNIA SO. WE'RE ALL WE'RE
ALL IN THE SAME I THINK WE'RE
ON THE SAME PAGE WE JUST HAVE
TO FIND OUT. THE RIGHT WAY TO.
PUT WHATEVER WE'RE GOING TO
FINALLY DECIDE ON THAT PAGE AND
IT HAS TO BE I THINK A
COMPROMISE. ON A FEW. BUT WE
WILL GET THERE SO INCREASE THAT
I FORWARD WORKING WITH YOU. AND
IT STERN ANY OTHER I'LL BE OF
OUR OF OUR STATE CALLED GROUP.
THANKS AGAIN THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES ENDED I STAY BY MY- NOT
JUST TO WE UNTIL NAY YEAR BUT
PUT GENUINE EFFORT IN THIS
YEAR- WITH YOUR COMMUNITY- WITH
SOME OF THE ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING ON THE LINE- AND
COMMEND YOU AND YOUR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN YOUR REGION REALLY
FOR- NOT LETTING THIS ISSUE LIE
AND REALLY PUSHING IT TO THE
FORE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
VIGILANT ADVOCACY HERE- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS
AHEAD. I'M WITH FAT MEMBERS-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON IN THE
FILE- TO. THE NEXT UP IS SB
THIRTEEN OH ONE. DUE TO HEALTH
ISSUES- CENTER HUESO WAS NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE TO PRESENT
TODAY- SO I HAVE AGREED TO
PRESENT IN HIS STEAD SO VERY
BRIEFLY- THIS IS- SB THIRTEEN
OH ONE I GUESS I WILL. SINCE
OUR PRESENTING A PAN THE- GAVEL
SYMBOLIC- BACK TO YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT
TO CENTER STERN PRESENTING SB.
A LINE BY SENATOR HUESO. SO
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND I'M
ACTUALLY ON A 2% THIS BILL
BECAUSE A CENTER HUESO AND I
HAVE BEEN. WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR YEARS- SINCE I CAME
INTO THIS LEGISLATURE IN FACT
I'VE VISITED THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY ACTED WITH THE-
GOVERNMENT ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE CITY MUNICIPAL
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THESE
MATTERS I TRULY THANK CENTER
HUESO FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND-
AN INSISTENCE ON ON PROGRESS
HERE- FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS THE TIJUANA RIVER VALLEYS
BEEN RAVAGED BY AS A JUST
CHARGE OF. TRASH SEDIMENT WASTE
WATER- RAW SEWAGE AND OTHER
WASTE THAT COMES THROUGH THIS
VALLEY POSES SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH RISKS THAT TRANSCENDED
NATIONAL BORDERS- FROM
UNTREATED PARTIALLY TREATED
HUMAN INDUSTRIAL WASTE- TOXINS
VIRAL PATHOGENS BACTERIA
EQUALIZE I RIO. SOUTH HELLO
IT'S- PROBABLY IN FACT IN THE
PASSING DIEGO HEADED QUEST OF
EMERGENCY. AND AN AVERAGE
WEEKEND ABOUT FIVE AND A
MILLION GALLONS OF SEWAGE FLOW
FROM MEXICO INTO THE VALLEY TO
THE INACTION- IN THAT REGION SO
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO.
BUILD SOME KIND OF PARTNERSHIP
HERE AND- I'VE BEEN JOINING
SENATOR HUESO IN SOME OF THESE
INNER. INTERFACES WITH- THE FOR
THE GOVERNMENT DOWN THERE AND
REALLY APPRECIATED MOVING FOR
TO LOOK FOR TO PARTICIPATING IN
UPCOMING CONVERSATIONS WE THINK
THIS BILL- IS AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF THE FRAMEWORK
FUNDING IS OBVIOUSLY GOING TO
BE VERY IMPORTANT AS WELL THERE
IS SOME MONEY IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE ALSO KNOW THE
INTERNATIONAL. BOUNDARY AND
WATER COMMISSION. HAS REALLY
YET TO LEAN IN AND BUILD THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE TO FIX
THE PROBLEMS OF CALIFORNIA'S.
REALLY STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE
AND TRY TO DO THAT OURSELVES-
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID
RECENTLY ALLOCATE CHANGE
MILLIONS OF THE RIVER VALLEY
THE PROJECT IDENTIFIED SOLVES A
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR DEFERRED OR WHICH WILL
CAPTURE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
MILLION GALLONS OF RAW SEWAGE-
AND CITIZENS WE STOP THE SEWAGE
POLLUTION AFTER FORTY YEARS OF.
AND CAN. SO THERE'S A MEMBER BI
NATIONAL WORK AT AS TO GO ON
THERE'S IMPORTANT STATE TO
STATE RELATIONS THAT HAVE TO GO
ON SO WE'RE OPEN AND THIS BILL
HELPS CREATE A FRAMEWORK. FOR
THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO IN
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IMPROVE THE
OVERALL HEALTH THE TIJUANA
RIVER WATERSHED WITH. WITH
FEDERAL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR EYES A- THANK YOU CENTER
STERN I UNDERSTAND WE DON'T
HAVE KEY WITNESSES. OKAY OR OR
IN OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT.
I WILL GO ANY WITNESSES IN
FORTY TWO OF THREE DOZEN
APPEARS WE IN TWENTY FORTY.
MISTER MODERATOR EITHER IF YOU
CAN ANNOUNCE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN OH ONE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF THERE ARE ANY. AND
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO- SEE YOUR SUPPORT IT'S ONE
ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM
THE LINE OF NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
AM I ON U. S. I THANK HER WOULD
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO
OTHER SINK YOUR THANK YOU AS
MODERATOR WILL GO TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. NINE TWENTY FORTY.
MISTER MODERATOR ON THE LINE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN OH ONE.
AND AS A REMINDER IT'S ONE ZERO.
ALLOWING A FEW MOMENTS WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR- ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE DíAS. WE HAVE A MOTION. NO
OTHER COMMENTS MISTER MOORE
JUST AS HE TRYING TO GET OUR
ATTENTION OR ANYTHING BUT SEE
NO REYES CAN'T OKAY SO WE HAVE
A MOTION. SENATOR I'M SORRY ONE
ONE CENTER CABALLERO AT THE
LAST SECOND WE CANNOT DEBATE
WITH. I JUST WANT TO BE YOU
KNOW. AT CENTER WEST WAS IN
HERE- BUT HE MAY BE WATCHING IF
IT'S CRAZY- AND SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL I THAT THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THERE'S SOME REAL NEED TO
PUT THE RESOURCES DOWN THERE
BUT- THE BILL DOESN'T ANSWER
HOW ALL THE OTHER WORKED IT'S
GONE BEFORE. MEASURES IN WITH
THIS SO I THINK THERE'S SOME
ELEMENTS MISSING- THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN WE GET INTO THE
BUSINESS OF. REPORTS ON TOP
REPORTS AND GROUP'S MEETING ON
TOP OF GROUPS AND THEN THEY
DON'T WORK TOGETHER AND THAT
DOESN'T HELP SO. I'M I'M GONNA
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT I THINK IT
NEEDS SOME WORK BEFORE COME TO
THE FLOOR. I HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS ON THE
LAYING OFF TODAY BUT AS A FROM
A PRIOR BOARD MEMBERS ANYWHERE
WHICH SERVICE YOU KNOW THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO GOOD WORK
DOWN THERE AND WE'LL KEEP
WORKING ON IT- SO WITH THAT. IF
THE- SURGERY CAN CALL OUR-
CONSULTING COLLEGES ALL I'M
SORRY. YOU LIKE. JUSTIN CLOSE.
IN RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR A
VOTE. I DO THINK THAT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL WORK THAT HAS TO BE
DONE ON THIS BILL FOR THE
FLORIDA THINK A LOT OF THE-
THE- THE- HOLD UP IS NOT ABOUT.
STUDIES AND REPORTS BUT MORE SO
ABOUT A FUNDING FRAMEWORK AND
SOME MUTUAL AGREEMENT TO MOVE
FORWARD AND- I'M I'M PRETTY
CONFIDENT CENTER HUESO. HAS
INTENT TO. TO HELP- WORK WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES TO THE SOUTH- TO
TRY TO GET THAT CONCRETE ACTION
FOR. WHICH REALLY. AT ISSUE
HERE IN THE BILL TODAY SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS CENTER
COPIER AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I'VE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL
THE ROLL. HE THE MOST IS PASS.
SB THIRTEEN OH ONE TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. HI I
JONES OF VOTING ALLEN ALLEN ARI
CABALLERO HI CABALLERO HI
HERTZBERG FORTY SO JACKSON
JACKSON ARI MONNING AYE AYE
MONNING HI. FIVE ZERO PUT IT ON
CALL OKAY- THAT MEASURES IT
FIVE ZERO WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR MOVING FORWARD- NEXT UP
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY WHICH IS. MY
BILL SO NOW PASSING IT
VIRTUALLY BACK TO YOU WITH AND
MR VICE CHAIR. IF YOU DON'T
MIND I'D LIKE TO PRESENT CENTER
STERN YOU MAY. WELL I WILL BE.
I WILL BE BRIEF- I DO NOT MEAN
TO BE INFLAMMATORY OR- OR-
OVERLY DRAMATIC IN MY LANGUAGE
BUT I TRULY THINK OF
UNMITIGATED CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
BANKRUPT NOT ONLY STATED
CALIFORNIA BUT- THE NATION AND
THE ENTIRE WORLD- I DO NOT
THINK WE HAVE AN ADEQUATE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FISCAL
RISKS I THINK WE HAVE A VERY
GOOD SENSE OF SCIENCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE DONE
GREAT WORK ON OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENTS BUT DRILLING
DOWN THE ACTUAL. PHYSICAL
LIABILITIES ON OUR BOOKS FROM
UNMITIGATED CLIMATE CHANGE IF
THAT'S A MATTER OF GETTING A
HEAD ON FIRE PREVENTION- IF
THAT'S A MATTER OF MITIGATING
SEA LEVEL RISE BEFORE IT-
SWALLOWS OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IF THAT IS A
MATTER OF GETTING AHEAD OF OUR
TRAP SO IT DOESN'T CAN'T
COLLAPSE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. WE STILL DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND ON A SECTOR BY
SECTOR BASIS WHAT THOSE
LIABILITIES ARE AND FRANKLY
WITH THE LIABILITIES ARE TO THE
GENERAL FUND AND I'M WORRIED
THIS YEAR EVEN IF WE GET HIT.
WITH ONE CATASTROPHE OR
MULTIPLE CATASTROPHES WE HAVE
NOT EVEN BUDGETED FOR THAT
CONTINGENCY IN OUR CURRENT
BUDGET YEARS OF THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET BETTER DATA
TO BOTH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SO WE CAN MAKE
SMARTER DECISIONS IN REAL TIME
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A
HYPOTHETICAL TWENTY FIFTY
STUDY- ONLY THIS IS ABOUT A
DRILLING DOWN A NEAR TERM
IMPACTS AND HOPEFULLY AVOIDING
THEM TO THE EXTENT WE CAN. I
HAVE JONATHAN PAR FREE WHO
REALLY APPRECIATE HIS WORK
CLIMBER SOLVE HERE'S A LEAD
WITNESS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A- THANK YOU. MISTER FEW
KEY DIAL UP MISTER PAR FREE
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. YES THIS IS LOUIS
BLUMBERG- JOHNSON WAS- CALLED
AWAY TO THE PHONE WAS NOT ABLE
TO PRESENT AND HE ASKED ME TO
GO IN AND REPRESENT HIM FOR
QUITE THERE WAS ALL. IT WAS
ALSO COURSE SB THIRTEEN TWENTY-
IT'S- RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE STAB WATCHING THE CRIME
IS ASSESSMENTS IN LAW. THE
PRIOR APPROACH TO THESE
ASSESSMENTS WAS HAPHAZARD AND
WITHOUT REAL DIRECTION
ORGANIZATIONS CERTAINTY. AS WE
SAY IN WHAT THE CODE SITUATION
THE IMPORTANCE OF GOOD UPDATES
ON. THIS IS CENTRAL TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE ANOTHER
DISASTERS. WE WANT TO APPLAUD
SENATOR STERN FOR INTEGRATING
INCLUDED ECONOMIC ANALYSES OF
HOW CLIMATE CHANGE CAN AND WILL
WILL AFFECT CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL
ACQUIRING IT'S A GREAT IDEA AND
IT'S IMPORTANT ADDITION TO THE
EVOLUTION OF THESE QUAN
ASSESSMENT THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING FOR MANY YEARS. WE
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDRESSING EXTREMELY WHICH. IS
INSUFFICIENT ATTENTION THEN OF
COURSE WE MUST CONTINUE AT THE
EXIT THE MAIN THE EGGS NO OF
THESE ASSETS. WHICH INCLUDE ALL
REPORT. STATE WHY ORIGINAL IN
OUR AND FOR STING LEADER POURED
READ LOCAL AND STATE. USING
CLIMATE. RESILIENCE ACTIONS
THAT IN THIS CONTEXT ADDING
ECONOMIC ANALYSES WOULD BE A
GREAT COMPLIMENT TO THE
STRUCTURE. NOW TRADITIONALLY
RESEARCH STUDIES HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE SCIENTISTS WHO
ARE EXPERTS IN THEIR FIELDS AND
THEN THERE BEEN DISTILLED INTO
THE CLIMB THE STEPS THAT WE
LIKE THAT IDEA IT'S BEEN
WORKING. AND WE BELIEVE ANY
ECONOMIC ECONOMIC CITY SHOULD
BE BROAD THE SCOPE- RATHER THAN
PRESCRIPTION WE SHOULD ALLOW
THE RECEIPT RESEARCHERS TO
RESPOND TO THE CRITERIA
DEVELOPED BY OPR. TO PROPOSE OR
INDIVIDUAL STUDIES BECAUSE THIS
IS WHAT THEY KNOW BASS. ONE
OTHER LITTLE POINT WE WANT TO
MAKE THIS IS IMPORTANT TO TALK
ABOUT ETHICS. FOR TARGET SHOULD
NOT SPECIFIC YEARS. BEYOND AS
SENATOR STERN I WANTED. TO ASK
FOR WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
PREVIOUS BILL THE IMPORTANCE OF
FUNDING- NOT IN THIS BILL BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOUR BE A
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING. FOR
THIS CLIMATE ASSESSMENTS WE NO
LONGER HAVE THE PEER PROGRAM
THAT WAS FUNDED FOR MANY YEARS
BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSIONS. PUBLIC GOODS
CHARGE SO WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR STERN BERGER
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS BILL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE TO POINT
YOU IN THE BILL AS A MOTION THE
PROCESS. IT'S AN IMPORTANT BILL
AND WE SUPPORTED
ENTHUSIASTICALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND YOU ONLY HAD ONE.
EXCEPT THE WITNESS REGARDLESS.
WHICH MARIN IF YOU CAN OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN TWENTY. ONCE AGAIN
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO THIS IS BRIAN SHOW I AM
EX CON TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AS WELL AS
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. WE HAVE NO
ONE FOR THEIR IN QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- AND TO GO
THROUGH THE ROOMS RIGHT. IS
THERE BUT IN TWENTY FOUR
ANYTHING IS GOOD TWENTY FORTY.
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TWENTY
FOURTEEN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND FORTY TWO OR
THREE. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN TWENTY FORTY. DIDN'T LOOK
LIKE IT AND MISTER MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. ONCE AGAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLUS ONE ZERO NOW.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ALL
LET'S ASK ONE MORE TIME IF
THERE'S WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. ON
THE LINE. MYSTERY. ONCE AGAIN
LEADING GERMAN PRESS ONE ZERO.
I THINK SO TWENTY THREE WITH ME
AS WE CANNOT. ALL RIGHT DOES
THAT NOBODY THERE. HELLO LINE
ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHEN I HEAR YOU MAN CREW
SO SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION SUPPORTED THE BILL.
THANK YOU. NO ONE FOR THEIR
QUEUE BY PHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER MARIO BRING BACK THE
DíAS QUESTIONS FROM THE DIS
SENATOR MINING AND THEN CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND. MY EXPECTATION IS
THE RESISTANCE DOWN THE ROAD
NOT A POLICY COMMITTEE BUT
MAYBE AROUND THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION I WOULD JUST
ARGUE IN ADVANCE OF THAT
REVIEW. THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL
INVESTMENT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND.
SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
SOME ARGUE THAT COVERT NINETEEN
IS A MANIFESTATION OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. MORE RECENTLY
ARE WILD FIRE CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS DISTORTED OUR
STATE'S BUDGET IT'S IMPACTED
MILLIONS OF RESIDENTS. MANY
TRAGIC LOSSES OF HUMAN LIFE AS
WELL AS PROPERTY WERE AT THE
PRECIPICE WITH THE CLIMATE
CRISIS OF NEEDING TO RETOOL.
HOW WE LOOK AT BUDGETING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW WE LOOK
AT BUILDING AND PROTECTING A
FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
GRAND CHILDREN IN GENERATIONS
AHEAD. TO ME THIS IS A MODEST
STEP BUT A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ONE SO THAT WE CAN BEST-
MANAGER LIMITED RESOURCES AND
ARE STRESSED RESOURCES TO
PROTECT OUR SHARED IN COMMON
FUTURE SO NOT REALLY A QUESTION
BUT A COMMENT IN SUPPORT AND
I'D BE GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR BYE SIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I AGREE WITH
THAT WITH SENATOR MINING AYE I
THINK THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS
TO BUILD AN ECONOMIC MODEL THAT
INCLUDES RURAL CALIFORNIA SO
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST WORRIED
ABOUT YOU KNOW. THE OCEAN
RISING SEA LEVEL RISE AND-
CLIFFS FALLING DOWN NOT IN THE
OCEAN BUT WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
THE IMPACT THAT THE ACTIVITY
HAS IN A BASIN THAT HAS NO WAY
FOR THE ERROR THE POLLUTED AIR
TO GET OUT OF IT ONCE IT GETS
IN THERE- AND THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT IT HAD IT HAS ON THE
HEALTH OF THE INHABITANTS BUT
ALSO. THE ROLE THAT AGRICULTURE
PLAYS IN- SO QUITE SO QUITE
STRING CARBON AND- YOU KNOW THE
I THINK THIS- THIS WHOLE
COALBED. PANDEMIC HAS GIVEN US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE. THE
IMPACT. OF OUR- DAY TO DAY LIFE
HOW IT IMPACTS. OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND THE FACT THAT THE AIR IS
pNEVER BEEN CLEANER THAT THE
ROADS ARE ARE PRETTY EMPTY AND
THAT ALL OVER THE WORLD YOU'RE
SEEING WILDLIFE. COME BACK IN A
WAY THAT NONE OF US WOULD HAVE
PREDICTED- SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME THERE'S SOME ECONOMIC
ISSUES THAT WE MAY BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT CAN HELP US GET-
ON THAT CAN HELP US TO REDUCE
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
MUCH FASTER AND- SO I THINK YOU
KNOW SO I WOULD ASK THE RATHER
THAT THEN BE PRESCRIPTIVE IN
THIS. LEGISLATION THAT WE
PROVIDE SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LOOKING AT THINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY- BECAUSE THERE ARE
OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD
THAT ARE DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND ARE HAVING SOME
SOME SUCCESS SO I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. OUT SO EN AND SO
AS A FOOTNOTE I THINK YOU
SHOULD OUT AT THE DEPARTMENT
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AS ONE OF
THE CONSULTING DEPARTMENTS SO
THAT WERE MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE INCLUDING THAT AS
WELL. THANK YOU. I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT MAKES A 100% SENSE
AND- OF THE WAS IN TEND TO BE
IN- OVERSEEING THE TIME LOOKING
PASTINJECTED THE SPEARS AND
AGRICULTURE AND IT'S LIKE THIS
YEAR. I MEAN THE MEGADRIVE IS
HERE NOW. GROUNDWATER
SUBSIDENCE HERE RIGHT NOW
POTENTIAL FOLLOWING OF YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW THE NUMBERS IT'S ALL
VERY SCARY SO- WE NEED TO BE
MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT BUT
MAYBE IF WE CAN BE SORT OF MORE
COMPREHENSIVE IT WON'T. YOU
KNOW WE DON'T NEED TO SIR TO
DRILL PIECE BY PIECE BUT- I
APPRECIATE THAT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS CENTER
JACKSON. IS I TO WILLOW WANTED
THANK YOU FOR THIS. YOU KNOW
WE'VE KNOWN FOR A LONG TIME
CLIMATE CHANGE IS OCCURRING AND
IT IS OCCURRING ALL OVER. IT
DID IT'S NOTHING THAT IS UNIQUE
TO ANY PARTICULAR PART OF THE
STATE. OR THE COUNTRY- AND IN
FACT I REMEMBER YEARS AGO WHEN
WE HAD SOMEONE TESTIFYING I
THINK IT WAS A SCIENTIST ABOUT.
THE PROSPECTS OF WHAT THE
CHANGES IN THE CLIMATE MEAN-
USING THE OCEAN AS AN EXAMPLE
BUT THE FACT THAT WHEN THE
WATER TEMPERATURE RISES HE
GIVES RISE ALSO TO BACTERIA
THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
AND THAT IT AFFECTS THE ENTIRE
FOOD CHAIN WHETHER IT'S IN THE
OCEAN WHETHER IT'S IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHETHER IT'S IN
YOU KNOW MINNESOTA. OR KANSAS
AND SO- I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT THIS
IS A SHOT ACROSS THE BOW WE
HAVE THIS VIRUS AND NOBODY'S
EVER SEEN OR HEARD OF BEFORE.
MY FEAR IS THAT GIVEN THE
CHANGES THAT THE CLIMATE IS
GOING TO THIS IS. NOT THE LAST
THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE AND WE'VE
SEEN THEM COMING OVER THE
COURSE WE WERE WE STARTED WITH.
I THINK WAS SARS IN THE BOWL OF
WHEN YOU THINK OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS THE NUMBER OF
THESE POTENTIAL PANDEMICS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED ENDING MEASURE
THAT WHICH MINOR SEES A
SCIENTISTS ARE SAYING THEY'RE
CONNECTED. BETWEEN THE INCREASE
THE TEMPERATURE. AND THE
CREATION OF ALL OF THESE NEW.
NO POP A BOWL BY THREATENING
COULD. I IT. WHEN WE ALL COME.
ON THIS AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT AND- I'M GLAD THAT WE
ARE TALKING NOW IT IS SOMETHING
THAT AFFECTS US ALL- AND DOES
NOT LIMIT ITSELF TO ONE
PARTICULAR PART. OF AN AREA AND
IT'S JUST REAL AND- IT
SHOULDN'T BE POLITICAL- SO I
HOPE THAT IS A CAUSE FOR WE ARE
ALL SITTING AT THE TABLE
TOGETHER AND- WORKING AT COM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR THE
S. NOW WE DO HAVE A MOTION I
THINK IT WAS FROM CENTER
MONNING- SO YOU MAY CLOSE AT
THE MYSTERIES CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS THREE COMMENTS AT.
I WAS GOING TO THE LANGUAGE
AND- WE- WE- WHILE WE DO CALL
OUT AGRICULTURE. AS WELL AS
FISHERIES AND- NUMBER OF OTHER
ISSUES IN BUSINESS AND TRADING
EXTREME HEAT ON LABOR
PRODUCTIVITY A NUMBER OF OTHER
IMPACTS WE TRY TO BE PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE BUT- WE'LL WE'LL
BE WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
HOPEFULLY FLESH THIS OUT AND DO
THIS INTO THE CURRENT DIALOGUE.
I THINK THE FACT WE'RE DEBATING
ABOUT TO PUT. A FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR BOND ON THE BALLOT IN IF
THAT'S TO ME TO COMMIT TO THE
FIGHT. THE MISTAKES THE SCOPE
OF THE FIGHT AND- WE'RE TALKING
IN A SINGLE DIGIT BILLIONS IN
TERMS OF EXPENDITURES ON
MITIGATION WHETHER IT'S HELPING
AGRICULTURE THROUGH THIS SIR.
OUR COASTAL REGIONS ARE THOSE
WHO ARE EXPOSED TO FIRE. ONE OF
MARK STORM THE USGS MODEL THIS
ARC STORM THEY USED THE NUMBERS
BASED ON THE EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO
GREAT FLOOD THAT CENTER
GOVERNOR TO THIS VERY CAPITAL
IN A CANOE. DOT IF WE IF WE HAD
A SIMILAR FLOOD- IN MODERN DAY
CALIFORNIA THE ESTIMATED THE
COST IMPACT AT SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE BILLION. DOLLARS ON
ONE FLOOD ALONE- THE OVERALL
ESTIMATES ON GLOBAL COSTS ARE A
RECENT STUDY PROJECTS FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY TRILLION DOLLARS
BY END OF CENTURY BUT THOSE
NEAR TERM- ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
YOU CAN ONLY CALL IT SORT OF A
BIBLICAL LEVEL OF PROPORTION
AND- OUR STORM WAS NAME OF
THEIR SCENARIO BUT- THE
DISRUPTIONS TO. URBAN CALLED
STOLEN LAND. JUST OF LIFE LINES
TO THE STATE FOR DAYS OR WEEKS.
I WOULD CAL. IF WE DON'T GET
AHEADOF IT THIS YEAR AND MOVE
REAL MONEY AND REALLY GET A
SENSE OF THE ECONOMIC VALUE OF
THAT NEAR TERM ACTION- I WORRY
WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE UNDER
WATER IN ONE FORM OR ANOTHER-
SO WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IPHONE. THANK YOU WE CAN
CALL THE ROLL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY STERN. BY KERN I'D JONES
JONES NO ALAN AND ALAN ARE LIKE
OF EURO I CAN BE A REAL AYE
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON HI
JACKSON ARE AYE MONNING AYE
MONNING HI. FIVE ONE- BUT ON
CALL OKAY WELL THAT MEASURES
BEING LEFT ON CALL AT FIVE ONE
AND FOR A FINAL BILL WE HAVE A
CENTER ALLEN MISS BE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY. YOU ARE A THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'VE I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL- EVEN THOUGH WE STILL OWE
YOU A DEFINITION ON
ENCROACHMENT- WE GLADLY ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. SO THIS BILL SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX TO SAVE THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY VALUABLE TIME AND
RESOURCES BY ALLOWING THE
CONSERVANCY THE RIGHT TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS ENCROACHMENT
ISSUES AND LANA GLACIATIONS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. SO JUST TO
EXPLAIN TO FOLKS- S. IN AND SEE
THE SENATE AMOUNTS CONSERVANCY
FREQUENTLY ENCOUNTERED
ENCROACHMENTS ONTO ITS LAND.
ALTHOUGH THESE ARE TYPICALLY
MINOR ENERGY SENT LANDOWNER
BUILT A DRIVEWAY OR SWIMMING
POOL ON CONSERVANCY LAND FOR
EXAMPLE- THE CONSERVANCY
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT RULES.
IS REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH A
COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING STATE
PROCESS TO TRANSFER THAT LAND
TO THE LANDOWNER IN EXCHANGE
FOR ANOTHER PARCEL OR WHICH IS
OFTEN. YOU KNOW THE WHOLE
PROCESS IS OFTEN MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN THE THAN THE LAND PARCELS
WORTH SO- SINCE THE
CONSERVANCY'S LAND IS STATE
OWNED. ANY ACQUISITION OR
DISPOSAL ITS LAND IS SUBJECT TO
THE STATE'S PROPERTY
ACQUISITION LAW. AND THEREFORE
REQUIRES WORKING THROUGH THE
STATE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD AND
APART A GENTLE SERVICES TO SELL
TRANSFER OR EXCHANGE INTERESTS
IN REAL PROPERTY THAT'S ALL
VERY GOOD AND IMPORTANT- BUT-
FOR REASONS THAT I THINK YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE EXPLAINED I WILL
TALK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT WE'VE
WE'VE GIVEN SOME LEVEL
FLEXIBILITY TO. CONSERVANCY'S
BASICALLY THIS BILL PUTS I THE
SAME AMOUNTS CONSERVANCY. INTO
A PLACE OF GENERAL PARITY WITH
THE CONSERVANCY'S IN GIVING
FLEXIBILITY- YET TO ALLOW THE
STAFF OF THE CONSERVANCY TO
WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE PROPERTY
OWNERS DISTRESS TO ADDRESS-
ENCOURAGEMENTS IF THE VALUE OF
SUCH PROPERTY INTERESTS IS LESS
THAN HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
THE TAHOE CONSERVANCY FOR
EXAMPLE. AS A THIRTY TO
ACQUIRE. OUR PROPERTY VALUE TO
UNDER FIVE IN A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. I FOR EXAMPLE SO-
ANYHOW AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
AMENDMENTS NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL. I TO ONLY ADDRESS THE
CONSERVANCY'S ABILITY TO
ACQUIRE LAND FROM THE WILLING
SELLER WHO HAS ENCROACHED. AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE CONSERVANCY AND TGS. ON
LANGUAGE TO COVER EFFICIENTLY
TRANSFERRING THECAN SERVICES
LAND THAT HAS BEEN BUILT UPON.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS INSTANCES IN WHICH A
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCY OR UTILITY
REQUEST THE LAND TRANSFER.
FIRST OF ALL OUR RIGHT OF WAY.
NOW WITH THESE REMAINING ISSUES
WORKED OUT THE BILL. WILL
ENABLE CONSERVANCY ULTIMATELY
TO FIGHT MORE EFFECTIVELY TO
FILL ITS MISSION OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC LANDS- PROVIDING RECORD
IT RECREATIONAL. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS CERTAINLY
THOSE IN- YEARS OF MY DISTRICT
MISTER CHAIR- WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON THE BILL AB JEFF
MALONEY USE CHIEF. STAFF
COUNSEL SMM CNA I KNOW I KNOW
THE NOW STOCK LIMIT. YOU KNOW
EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THE
HEADACHES HE CAN SPEAK TO THE
SOME OF THE HEADACHES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS- WITH
THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. I WILL GO TO YOUR-
LEAD SUPPORT. MISSED OWNING.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD CALL ON
THE LEAD WITNESS ON THE LINE.
HI I LINE. WHICH THANK YOU AS
CHAIR- BUT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JEFF WILLIAMS YOU CAN STAFF
COUNSEL TO THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY. IS FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMIT YOUR TIME ON THIS
BILL TODAY AT THE END OF THE-
OF THE- HEARING SO. THANKS FOR
SITTING THROUGH IT ALL. SPECIAL
THANKS TO SENATOR ALLEN FOR
LEADING THE CHARGE IN PROPOSALS
LEGISLATION- CENTER ALLEN
COVERED A LOT OF MY COMMENTS
BUT JUST SHOULD JUST WALK
THROUGH THE CONSERVANCY THE
STATE AGENCY. AND THE
MINISTRATION HASN'T YET WEIGHED
IN ON THIS MATTER SO WE'RE NOT
IN A POSITION TAKERS FOR MOLD-
SUPPORTER OF OPPOSED. THE BILL
BUT I OBVIOUSLY WECOME THE
OPPORTUNITY GIVE SOME FEEDBACK
ABOUT HOW THIS. LEGISLATION
WOULDN'T IMPACT US. YOU'RE IN
THE BILL AND NOW THE BILL
PROVIDE THE CONSERVANCY WITH
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE
RECURRING PROBLEM. TO THE
CONCORD TRENDS. LAN THANK
QUESTIONS INCLUDE EVERYTHING
FROM SMALL BASED GARDENS TENNIS.
TO EVEN ON. BILL SUCH IN
COURTROOMS ARE REALLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR US FOR VARIOUS
REASONS INCLUDING. THE OBVIOUS
DAMAGE TO THE NATURAL HABITAT
WHICH IS OUR MISSION TO
PROTECT. INCREASED BY. STATE OR
WHATEVER IMPROVEMENTS ARE THERE
AND JUST OVERALL DIFFICULT
TRICK DIFFICULTY. IN MONITORING
LANDS UNDER STATE OWNERSHIP OUR
NEW SITUATIONS ARISE. IN
CERTAIN SITUATIONS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND IS OUR WAY TO
ADDRESS THE COURT WILL BE TO
CONVEY TITLE TO THE AFFECTED
AREA TO BE CHANGED. OWNER IN
EXCHANGE FOR TILE TO OTHER
PROPERTY OWNED BY A COLLECTION
PART ABOUT THE ONLY THING WE
CAN DO BUT SOMETIMES THE BEST
THING WE- THIS. SO THE
TRANSACTION AND ALLOW US TO.
AND MORE CHRISTIAN THE
ADDRESSES. CURRENTLY AS YOU
HEARD WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE- PUBLIC WORKS FOR AN
APPROPRIATE PROPERTY
ACQUISITION LAW AND MOST THE
TIME THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM FOR
LARGER ACCUSATIONS OF COURSE.
WHY WOULD THAT BE THESE ARE
TYPICALLY SMALLER PIECE OF
PROPERTY AND THE B. B. PROCESS
CAN OFTEN SERVE AS A
DISINCENTIVE TO OUR AGENCY AND
A PRIVATE PARTIES TO RESOLVE
THIS WELL HERE'S WHAT THE
EXPENSE AND THE TIME- THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION WOULD
FACILITATED DESTINATION PRIVATE
LAND THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
CONSERVANCY TO FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTION TO ENCOURAGEMENT. AND
TIME AND TIME AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER SO ARE WE
DON'T IT OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS
WOULD ALLOW US TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY MANAGER PROPERTIES
AND TO ENSURE THE CONTINUED
PROTECTION OF CRITICAL OPEN
SPACE AND HAVE A CHAT IN
AROUND. MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREAS SO- ALL ALL ALL LEAVE IT
AT THAT THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS THERE ARE
ON ON THIS TOPIC- BUT AGAIN
THANKS TO CARE AND THANK YOU
SENATOR. FOR THANK YOU MISTER
MALONEY. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
IN SOME HERE IN FOR. TWO OH
THREE. SEE NONE AVIDIN TWENTY
FOUR. SEE NONE MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND LOOKING IT UP
PUBLIC SUPPORT- ON OUR CALL
LINE. OKAY ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO DO SUPPORT IT'S
ONE ZERO. WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD- LET'S MOVE OVER AND SEE
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
EITHER LEAD OR OTHERWISE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE OR TWENTY FOUR.
CONTEST BUT OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY ANYONE O THE
LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN A
POSITION TO BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY.
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING
UP IN OPPOSITION OKAY- SEEING
NO- MORE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
AT THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH THEIR
COMMITTEE- AND TO YOUR STAFF
AND COMMITTEE STAFFER REALLY
REFINING IS TO. FOCUS ON THE
PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE-
AND- BUT BUT WITHOUT
SACRIFICING ANY TRANSPARENCY
THE PUBLIC- AND REALLY
CLARIFYING THAT THIS ISN'T-
WAIT A GIVE SAY EMINENT DOMAIN
AUTHORITY OR SOME OTHER- THAN
SOME OTHER AUTHORITIES BUT
REALLY FOCUSING SQUARELY ON
THIS ISSUE OF ENCROACHMENT HOW
TO RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES HAVE
MORE CREATIVELY COST
EFFECTIVELY IN A WAY THAT- HAS
PARITY WITH THE OTHER AGENCIES
ALLIED. CLOSE HELLO SORRY THEN
GO OTHER MEMBERS THIS A QUICK
QUESTION I THINK YOU HANDLE IN
YOUR OPENING IS GOING TO
CONFIRM YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY YES OKAY AND
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANKYOU CENTER. YOU DID MY
JOB FOR ME I SHOULD HAVE ASKED
THANK YOU YEAH. OKAY YEAH I
KNOW I THINK YOU I THINK THE
CHAIR DID A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
ARTICULATING WHERE WE WERE WE
GOT TO ON THIS BILL AND I AB
MEETS THE CORE GOALS THAT WE
HAVE WHILE ON. ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT PROTECTING THE PROCESS AND-
OUR PUBLIC CONTROL OVER. OVER
OVER OVER THE PROCESS IS I MEAN
I UNDERSTAND WHY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- PUT
PROCESSES IN PLACE TO PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC TRUST ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE. LANDS BUT THIS THIS
FINDS A- NOW AGAIN AND
REASONABLE COMPROMISE. TO
ADDRESS THE SORTS OF CHALLENGES
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE GENERAL
COUNSEL SO WITH THAT I RESPECT
FOR US FROM ABOUT. VERY GOOD-
DO WE PROMOTION. YEAH SO THE
MOTION FROM SENATOR MONNING IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHIEF
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED
STERN HI STERN ALRIGHT JUNE
SIGN JONES HI ALAN HI. ALLEN HI
COVER EURO FIVE ZERO ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG. HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON OFF BY MONNING I AM
MONNING HI. THAT HAS SIX LONG
CALL HERTZBERG OKAY WE WILL
LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL-
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE- YOU ARE
DONE WITH YOUR VOTING DUTIES IN
THE FILE IS OVER I'M GOING TO-
WAIT A MINUTE BEFORE WE ADJOURN
JUST TO MAKE SENSOR SENATOR
HERTZBERG HAS A CHANCE. OF
GALLAGHER. I'M SORRY SO LET'S
LET'S LEAVE THE CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHILE WE'RE-
WAITING OUR FINAL MEMBER. CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS S. B.
THE FILE ITEM TO SB NINE EIGHT
NINE COMMA ZERO I HAVE YOUR
OHIO HERTZBERG HUESO. OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON
CALL. MEMBERS YOU ARE FREE TO
MULTI TASK OR MOVE ON TO
WHATEVER DUTIES YOU SO DESIRE
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU SIR
YEAH THANKS. SO OFF TO A GOOD.
SIX OF THE SITE YEAH CAN LOW IN
THE HOUSE. IN THE COMPUTER NO
NO THERE'S ONLY BY PASSING A-
WHERE THEY GOING THEY'RE GOING
TO. HOUSE AND IN RIGHT KNEW THE
PART OF AN ACTUAL.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIMELY APPEARANCE
CENTER HERTZBERG. SO WE'LL WALK
YOU THROUGH IT REAL QUICK HERE
BUT WE HAVE SIX ITEMS BUT ONLY
FIVE WILL BE VOTED ON HERE AND
WE WILL START AT THE TOP WHEN
YOU ARE FEEL READY- THE FIRST
ITEM IS SB ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE
STERN- CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ZERO HERTZBERG
HI HERTZBERG HI HUESO OKAY OKAY
THAT FILLS OUT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE- FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB NINE
EIGHT NINE DOLLY CHIEF
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM TO
SB NINE EIGHT NINE HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
OKAY THE MEASURE IS OUT TO
CLOSE THE ROLE FILE ITEM THREE
IS NOT BEING VOTED ON FILE ITEM
FOR SB THIRTEEN OH ONE CENTER
HUESO. A CHIEF CONSULTANT CORAL.
THE FILE ITEM FOR THIS BE
THIRTEEN OH ONE JONES.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
HI HUESO. OKAY THAT MEASURES UP
PLEASE CALL THE CLOSE THE ROLE
FILE IN FIVE SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
STERN THE CHIEF CONSULTANT CALL
THE ROLL. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY.
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG ALL
RIGHT HUESO. OKAY THERE
MEASURES OUT PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND FINALLY A FILING
MEMBER SIX SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SENATOR ALLEN- CHIEF CONSULTANT
CALL THE ROLL. THIS BE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY HERTZBERG HI THE SPUR
GUY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
CLOSE THE ROLE THAT MEASURE IS
OUT- SEEN ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
MOVED THANK YOU ALL MEMBERS
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.